Really California.
I don't even know where Eureka,
California.
It's about 200 miles north of San
Francisco.
Oh,
in the middle of weed country.
The whole,
the whole state's wheat country now.
But I'm going to look at a weed deal.
Can I just tell you that you are
impeccably dressed in a very unique and
original way.
Thank you.
I mean your dress really well,
but I've never seen a guy dressed as
well as you with such unusual colors and
the tie and the shirt and my wife
dresses me.
Does she?
Yeah.
Just try and keep you from getting laid.
That's what it is.
Well Sally,
can you figure that she's making you
just look real flamboyant where people
just don't know what to think.
Yeah,
I liked the whole thing.
The scarf you got in the pocket.
Yeah.
This,
this is how I dress though.
Can you pull this out right up to,
sorry.
These things are very directional.
Um,
if you don't know how I dress all the
time.
Yeah,
I got it.
Well,
I mean at the house I a boxer shorts and
a tee shirt,
does it?
Yeah.
In the house.
And then outside,
outside,
and I'm normally dressed as us or in my
uniform.
My three piece suit.
Yesterday I gave a talk in beverly hills
to some kids and I was in my three piece
suit.
What did you ever talk about?
Uh,
one of my mentees is a guy named Jason
capital who is the,
he doesn't say it this way,
but he is the preeminent expert in how
to get laid a and he's got ninth,
quite as many followers as you do,
but a million or a million and a half.
Really?
And it's just teaching people how to get
laid.
No,
no,
no.
He doesn't build self esteem.
Oh,
but I mean,
but at the end of the day,
all these little weenies went to get
laid.
So he teaches them how to not be a
little weenie anymore.
Correct.
Man up or something.
And so he asked me if I'd talked to his,
he's got different programs,
you know,
the game they sell up,
sell up,
sell up.
So was premier group I talked to
yesterday,
said it's about 60 70 guys who obviously
must pay the most money to a monthly.
Yeah,
but he's got 40,000 people that pam,
between 80 bucks and 3000 a month.
What?
Yeah.
That's insane.
Fucking right.
I know.
And he's just teaching them how to be a
man.
Be a man.
How did I,
how did he,
um,
his dad beat the fuck out.
I'm just like,
my dad beat me.
Oh Wow.
That's what we need more.
And Jason capital's not as,
not not his name.
He's got a,
a,
a Polish name.
He's from Detroit,
but that's a big secret,
that name.
But,
but he's Jason capital and he's good
looking.
He's a really good looking guy.
Well that helps if you want to get laid.
Yeah.
But then if you want to teach people how
to get laid,
that helps.
You can't really teach that though.
Like you can't teach being a good
looking guy.
Yeah.
Well no,
but I,
I told the kids,
um,
when I was their age,
I got,
and I was single and pre-aids I got more
ass than a toilet seat at the bus
station.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
But I did.
And last night I had dinner with a buddy
of mine who unfortunately,
he's the guy,
the agent orange now,
he's got orange here on marine here from
Vietnam.
And he was one of the guys that I used
to run around with.
And uh,
I brought back some of the memories in
his daughter's going,
you mean you were a slut
dad?
Whoa.
And uh,
and she talks about that in front of the
young lady.
And then I was,
sorry,
I brought up the subject.
Yeah,
you can't do that for certain Giles'
especially today.
Yeah,
man.
Horns not appreciated anymore.
No,
no,
no.
So this guy's a,
I can't believe people are paying $3,000
a month.
What could it possibly be giving them
for $3,000 a month?
Well,
content of some sort.
I've never looked at it,
so I can't really tell you content.
I mean,
content is the name of the game.
Jamie,
I need a mug buddy.
Sorry.
Content is the name of the game,
but it's 3000.
It seems like you'd have to come to your
house and give you back rubs.
I mean that's a lot of that getting
money,
man.
That's like a mortgage.
That's crazy.
$3,000 a month now.
The 80 a month.
I can,
I can understand why don't even,
that's a lot like what has he given you?
Netflix is nine bucks.
Can Watch documentaries to your ears,
bleed,
you know?
Yeah.
I've only turned my Netflix on a couple
of times.
The uh,
it's,
it's interesting,
but yeah,
so I was there,
gave a talk at,
ran over.
I talked to an a half hours and then I
went out to the,
to Valencia to see my buddy did the
marine guy for dinner and uh,
the uh,
took three and a half hours to get to
Valencia from Beverly Hills.
Yeah.
It's a ridiculous piece of traffic we
have out here.
Yeah.
So set of a scene of traffic.
It's pretty,
it's,
it's way worse than it was when I first
moved here in 94.
And I got a wonder what it's going to be
like 20 years from now.
It's going to be insane.
It's going to be,
well then hopefully they'll have hover
cars that knock each other.
Well,
we were talking about that yesterday.
We watched some clips from blade runner,
the movie that was supposed to be 2019,
like that's the only supposed to be two
years from now.
And that crazy didn't realize that
Harrison Ford.
Yeah.
Daryl Hannah,
um,
rutger hauer great movie.
Yeah.
One of my favorite all time Scifi
movies.
But yeah,
hard to believe that that was supposed
to be just a couple of years from now.
Like people really overestimated the
amount of technology we'd have by then.
Well,
I mean,
uh,
they overestimated that,
but in some,
some things they underestimated the
internet.
Yeah,
correct.
I mean,
when I first said 30 years ago,
the two things to get involved in,
we're healthcare and telecommunications
with morphed into the Internet.
I had no idea what the Internet was
going to be.
Uh,
you know,
people measure rotates,
returns on their investment and return
on the minute,
not returned on the hour or the month or
return on capital because things can
change,
you know,
in a few seconds.
But how do you feel about that?
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but how do you feel about that of a guy
that's been an investor for as long as
you've been?
What do you,
how do you feel about this new thing
where they're using computers and
algorithms to buy and trade?
Like literally at the speed of sound and
just click,
click,
click going back and forth depending on
the trends and they,
they're,
they're paying money to get a server
that's as close as possible to the
exchange so that they're living and they
were literally buying and selling in the
milliseconds or a millionth of a second
ahead of everybody else because they're
closer to the exchange.
I came up the old way.
I don't really,
uh,
I appreciate the,
the progress,
but I don't like it because I,
most people don't understand it.
And like I was tweeting this morning,
a gold's down,
uh,
oil broke a $48 a barrel or $49 a barrel
and a how was your 401k improved?
What are your gurus telling you to do
now?
The market's up.
Uh,
depending how you want to measure 20,
25%.
Since trump got elected on the 8th of
November,
and hardly anybody has benefited the
guys that had benefited of the guys who
drive the indices a,
he's created 3 billion,
$3 trillion if she's me in market cap on
the,
on the just the New York Stock Exchange.
Uh,
but most people haven't benefited
because 70 to 90%,
depending on how you want to count a or
calculate a of that money is a big
money,
rockefeller,
Pena,
trump,
et cetera.
And so the average guy,
the average joe didn't benefit.
You know,
I ask anybody listening,
check your 401k or your pension plan,
tell me how much it's up since November
8th most people say nothing.
Nothing.
So I'm a part of that is just what you
were alluding to the algorithms,
because it's the f fast,
big money that's making all the big
money.
Although a hedge funds have fallen out
of favor the last couple of years
because their returns haven't been the
same as even the indices.
So your feeling,
how do you feel about the things that
trump is doing right now and the way
he's,
uh,
you know,
he's,
he's bringing on all these guys that
have worked for these major corporations
like Exxon and he's,
they're doing that,
the whole thing that he announced the
other day of creating 45,000 jobs and
they'll go in the golf coast.
And like,
if you look at it,
um,
there was a thing on the New York Times
today,
I think that was talking about,
maybe it was time magazine.
It was talking about he's created
239,000 jobs since he's been in office,
which is,
uh,
what does it,
a couple of months,
not that long.
And so are you from a business
standpoint,
forget about like socially.
Well,
let flint business sandpoint claimer
first.
I know trump.
Okay.
And I knew them from that late eighties
in the,
um,
in the early nineties,
because one of my partners,
and one of my mentors was governor Hugh
Carey,
the former governor in New York.
So because of his New York relationship
and also one of my,
uh,
ex business partners with Mayor Wagner,
the former mayor of New York.
So I knew trump then.
So,
but I haven't,
I haven't talked to him in over 20
years.
But getting back to your original
question,
um,
the,
I believe that as,
um,
there's a reason why he's meeting with
all the ceos of all these major
industries because nobody else has ever
done it.
Uh,
I believe in,
as I endorsed him,
I was one of the early endorser's flip
trump and I said that,
um,
if he's serious
and he'll win,
he knows how to win.
He doesn't know how to lose.
If he's serious,
he's going to rock the fucking planet,
not just the u s but the world.
And the financial models are changing in
Europe.
Uh,
not just because of brexit.
The financial models are trainging,
uh,
in Russia,
the models are changing in,
in,
in China because they've got a guy,
I got an Alpha male in the office that
has surrounded himself with Alpha males.
It's no coincidence at 60% of his staff
are ex military.
I mean,
the press secretary is that God damn
Lieutenant Commander in the Navy,
uh,
you know,
not counting all the four star generals
that he's got.
Um,
so I don't agree with everything he
says.
I don't agree with everything he tweets.
I wouldn't tweet as many,
as much as he does,
but I do agree that the country needed
to change financial change and he's
going to bring it now whether he gets
elected a second term or not,
I don't know.
But I do believe,
and I've said Joe,
that this is the November the eighth was
the beginning of the greatest
transformation of wealth the planet has
ever fucking seen since World War II.
How so?
Because well,
I mean,
just look at $3 trillion so far in stock
market.
I believe it's going to be $100
trillion.
He's going to add to the market before
he's going to his office.
He's explained to a dummy like me dummy.
Okay.
Oh cool.
A Caterpillar,
even though they got in some trouble for
taxes,
they got raided a,
here are a couple of days ago.
You mean not a seller?
What are the caterpillar,
they make tractors.
Okay.
The infrastructure shot in this country.
Uh,
the bridges are all 40,
50,
60 years past their prime.
Okay.
I didn't know a bridge could go past its
prime.
Uh,
the roads are 50,
60,
70 years past their prime.
Uh,
the infrastructure for pipelines are
past their prime,
so he's going to rebuild all this.
He's gonna spend supposedly a $3
trillion,
uh,
which is not a coincidence that because
he added 3 trillion to the stock market,
but he's going to add infrastructure.
So all the stocks like Caterpillar,
a,
t,
and t,
uh,
Boeing,
etc.
Uh,
I've gone up 15,
20,
25,
30% since he got elected because the big
money,
the smart money,
uh,
knows that those companies are going to
get all the contracts.
The,
the real no brainer is aerospace,
aerospace,
not just because he cut the cost of a
air force one down 700 million or
whatever he did,
but because he's going to bring the
United States military back to what it
was under Reagan 30 years ago.
Um,
and being a vet myself,
uh,
I believe a strong country.
Uh,
I think we get involved in too much shit
outside of the country.
Okay.
But I mean a strong country then
nobody's going to,
you know,
screw with us.
He's going to bring back jobs.
Uh,
I believe he will build a wall.
And My mother and grandmother's swam
across the Rio Grande River as illegal
aliens in 1924.
25.
My,
my,
my mother,
God rest her soul.
We were just out at the cemetery a
couple of days ago.
Um,
the,
uh,
it wasn't a naturalized citizen until
she was in early thirties.
So,
um,
the,
but I figured out a way to pay for the
wall.
And Yours is the first show I'm going to
say it on.
Okay.
They arrested Guzman,
the great drug trafficker from,
okay.
They also confiscated $39 billion from
did it really?
He had heard the 9 billion.
Whoa.
Okay.
39.
It's Hashtag podcast,
I mean,
yeah.
Okay,
good.
So why not pay for the wall with his
money?
Yeah,
that's probably a good idea.
But do you think that a wall is a
feasible and it's a good idea to have
this?
I know it's feasible,
but I don't.
Um,
but I'm a,
I'm a guide that I would rather pull the
trigger and see if it works then not do
anything.
The biggest difference between most of
the kids that are out there trying to be
successful like yourself and some of the
other people you've interviewed here is
they spreadsheet at the death.
They read books,
they listen to podcast and they never do
a fucking thing.
Okay.
I've had kids come to my seminar that
ever read 700 books on personal
development.
I didn't know there was 700 bucks in
personal development.
Okay.
But they've never pulled the trigger
paralysis by analysis.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
That can definitely happen.
It can definitely happen.
And,
and the,
uh,
like the kids yesterday,
they'd all read books and I don't even
know what the charm books are.
I,
I have no idea.
There's actually a program called the
art of charm,
which is the same thing,
how to get laid.
That's not what they call it,
but it's,
there's a deal is exactly what it is.
Right.
I've looked at it and I've actually been
interviewed on the,
on the kid show.
That seems to me like saying something
like,
uh,
how to get famous instead of like just
get really good at something and you're
famous like how to get laid well,
just be a,
an excellent person and people want to
fuck it.
Yeah,
that's what I think.
Yeah.
Well I mean,
uh,
I,
I proved that for a lot of years.
Yeah.
I do ask,
but I mean a pre pre aids pre-aids yeah.
It's when you slow it down.
Well,
no,
I got married on a notch.
I got married,
I got married.
Yeah.
Everybody was scared.
People don't know.
Today kids aren't scared of AIDS
anymore,
but back in the 80s when Magic Johnson
got aids,
I will never forget where I was in my
car when he got HIV.
Rather when they announced it on the
radio,
I was driving in my car.
I was like,
oh my God.
It was like a scene in a Zombie movie
where you thought this was the
beginning,
this was the first one,
and then eventually was going to spread
across the entire country and everyone
you knew it was gonna play.
Yeah,
we were really worried.
We you single then.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I think I was 20 where you stand up
comic then.
Yeah,
just who's 21 I think.
Cause I know my research,
um,
they went of the things I saw was when,
I don't know if you were a teenager when
you were in a competition and you
knocked the guy cold in the first 10
seconds or two minutes or one minute.
It's on,
it's on the Internet competition you
were in,
I think he was still a teenager maybe.
I don't know.
Probably,
yeah.
Taekwondo tournament up had a lot of
that stuff.
And um,
the,
um,
but I mean,
you practice a lot to get good.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You have to.
If this doesn't happen,
well you don't.
Yeah.
You have to actually do it too.
It's exactly what you're talking about.
Yeah.
You could read theory all you want,
but until you got theories,
one thing and thoughts were another
thing.
But actions are critical.
You have to think about what happened
during the actions and be prepared to
fail.
Dalai Lama at his 80th birthday,
which I was not invited to and maybe you
want to find it.
No,
no,
no.
The Dolly,
he made a little speech and at the end
of the speech he's got a sentence.
Meditation is Great,
prayer is great.
A couple of other things are great,
but the best thing is taking action.
Action.
Okay.
And uh,
the,
um,
and so,
and this is what I,
uh,
I teach and,
the is to take action in a,
I've done a lot.
I have had a lot,
a lot of success,
but I've had a lot of failures,
but nobody's interested in my failures.
They're only interested in the,
you know,
the Times I've got it across the goal
line.
Well,
Thomson girl is a huge fan of yours and
that's how I found out about,
he thinks you're hilarious.
You're ruthless approach to coaching
people and advice.
It was pretty fun.
Yeah,
I mean when I had lunch with him a few
days ago,
uh,
I think I told you on the phone and I
was expecting he and his wife to be
keeping me rolling in the aisles and
they were straight.
They were like three trust and they
were,
yeah,
they were like,
preachers look at it.
It looks like picture man
ai.
He does.
He looks like he easily could be some
sort of a pastor was beautiful tie.
Look how slim me as to now.
Tom Seger kept the weight off.
Amazing.
Great.
He's lost like 60 pounds or something
crazy like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They had a competition with his friend
Bert Kreischer and they did it over two
days on the show.
Like they weighed in twice in a row.
And Tom,
Tom one the way in both days.
Yeah.
It was a big deal.
It was a big deal for him to,
I really think he lost more than 50
pounds,
which is pretty impressive.
Well,
a few years ago,
a 10 12 years ago,
I just decided at 60 and I was going to
become a power lifter.
I don't know what possessed me.
So I gained 65 pounds.
I took human growth hormones,
they did the whole nine yards and I got
up to two 80,
Jesus Christ.
And um,
and then,
uh,
I was trying to get the up to 300,
but I couldn't get up to 300 pounds
weight.
I tried like hell.
I mean I eat everything.
I eat everything on this table,
metal,
light and care.
Uh,
and then I realized that and then,
uh,
I also don't have the,
the,
the right bone structure.
And so,
um,
I decided that the,
there's certain things I can only do so
much weight.
So I was doing bench presses with my
son.
Uh,
at that time he was a 28 and a,
we were doing sets and,
um,
I heard this rip in my bicep and I kept
working out.
But what I had done is I ripped my long
head bicep.
And so,
um,
the,
but one of the reasons they call me the
bionic man,
because I just had two knee full knee
replacements in the last couple of
months.
I've got an artificial hip.
I have artificial shoulders.
Oh,
I have a titanium collarbone.
Oh.
And I don't have any long head bicep.
And so,
uh,
these are all,
what's a long head bicep muscles,
right.
It's the one that makes the Hump Right.
You don't have that one across the top?
No,
I don't have that one.
So yours just goes flat when you uh,
yeah,
but now my musters go flat anyway cause
I don't work out like I used to.
But you could have got that repaired.
He chose one.
I know I got to repair it.
Not once as they say in Texas is not
once,
not twice but three times.
And I fucked him up all three times.
How'd you pick it up?
He kept lifting.
Yup.
[inaudible] maniac to
powerlifting.
How long has to,
or how quick was too early?
Um,
two months.
Oh Jesus.
Yeah.
You can't do that.
I like,
and my knees,
they told me I had the second knee done.
Yeah,
I weighed at 10 weeks.
But they were right and I was wrong.
Yeah,
I would imagine there would be.
Right.
And you would be wrong.
I,
yeah.
So now when I get up from here,
you'll see how I get up gingerly.
So Wa like when they build you an
artificial knee,
it does,
it does.
It did they chop off the top of your
knee?
Screwed in place at the top and the
bottom femur.
And then they put like a joint like this
and then it has these like spikes that
go into the bone marrow and they cement
them.
No Jews.
They didn't tell you tell me.
It's,
see your knee goes like this moves both
ways,
but my knees only go this way.
Goes up and down.
So I had to relearn how to put my socks
on because when you put your socks on,
your leg swings over.
You can't swing your legs.
No,
no.
So there's a little sideways movement.
Correct.
Jesus Christ.
That seems like it would be severely
limiting,
right?
Yeah.
Well it is.
Well I,
the uh,
I don't think I'll be when in martial
arts you say we're going to roll and
then I,
you won't be,
it won't be rolling.
Now did you,
did you have ligament damage or meniscus
damage?
I had three surgeries on my right knee
for the,
all of the above.
And I had one surgery on my left knee.
Why they decided to replace the entire
name cause I had no cartilage left.
I was bone on bone from running tens of
thousands of miles.
I,
when I went to,
um,
a biohack a couple of years ago,
I didn't even know what that meant.
Biohacking and I went to the bio hacking
and all the guys and I met a guy I
really liked to seen it.
Was there a guy named to Siena and uh,
the,
uh,
all these things I've been doing since
the 70s,
I ran a hundred miles and piss blood,
which used to be the benchmark.
If you are a man and a runner,
you run a hundred miles and you piss
blood.
Okay.
That's makes you man.
Yeah.
Because yeah,
that's what that,
that's that then it did.
And I've done,
can you breathe?
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And I,
you know,
I've run marathons and I run a lot,
a lot of miles and uh,
my knees paid for it,
so I haven't really been able to run in
20 years.
Have you ever looked at a stem cell
therapy for it?
Yes,
I have.
As a matter of fact,
I'm going to Mexico and a couple of
months.
I tried it 25 years ago when it first
came out in Switzerland.
They're doing it here.
No,
I won't have to go to Mexico.
I didn't know they were doing.
Yeah.
I'll,
I'll talk to you after the show.
There's a great place in Vegas,
you know that they're a,
they're doing it,
but they've been able to regenerate
meniscus,
tissue,
cartilage,
all sorts of things like that.
It's a,
it's a slow process,
but it can be done now.
Okay.
But when it seems like yours is gone
now,
can you like play tennis?
Can you move around?
Can you go side to side?
I can go this way.
I strive to move this way.
Oh Wow.
I can't move out.
You couldn't tell why you're walking?
No,
no,
no.
I'll walk away.
It's,
you know,
um,
as Fernando Lamas,
still great actress said many years.
What's better?
Fernando Lamas.
He says it's better to look good.
Feel good.
Well he's,
I don't know if he's right.
He was married to Esther Williams.
I think he's wrong.
I think he's definitely wrong.
I think
you're better off feeling good and
looking good because if you look good
and you feel like Shit,
you live in hell.
But if you look like shit,
but you feel fantastic,
as long as no one's looking at you and
you know,
freaking out,
what do you care,
right?
Yeah,
I think he's wrong.
So,
um,
your knee and your hips,
like what wwe did the hip do,
they saw the top of your hip off to do
the same.
Same thing.
Oh Jesus.
So you've got to the top of your femur
and the bottom of your femur saw dogs.
Jesus.
Dan,
you kill a bear with a knife.
I slowed it down with a handgun and then
I killed it with a knife.
The knife was what was going on in the,
um,
well let me just say I have three
regrets in life.
Um,
it leads into this,
the segway,
it will become obvious.
First regret is a,
uh,
the,
the day before my mom died,
I told him,
you're not fucking sick.
You're not fucking sick or you're not
going to die.
She dies the next day.
Okay.
Second regret I have is the fact that,
uh,
I'm a combat trained army officer who
never saw combat.
Okay.
Never gotten any real trigger time.
Uh,
the third regret is that I didn't set my
goals high enough is successful as I am.
Okay.
So because,
uh,
I,
I tried to get involved with mercenary
things.
Uh,
uh,
when I got out of the military about 10
years,
cause I had done very well as far as
business was concerned.
And um,
the,
um,
but the,
I actually did a joint venture with the
CIA.
It's all public record now.
And the I statue of limitations passed
so I can't get in any trouble.
And uh,
that didn't work out.
So I decided to go do big game hunting.
And see if I can,
you know,
so I started with the rifles.
I know some guys do beaus I believe you
do a then I that was too easy.
Then I did a hand gun,
hand gun handgun,
four or five,
four console used to be the biggest
handgun made 25,
30 years ago.
So I hunted handgun.
And you gotta get pretty close handgun.
How close you get.
Um,
well I've been as close as you to what?
To the charging buffalo.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
A buffalo was charging to disclose.
And you shot him with a handgun?
Yeah,
I got run over by him.
Oh,
well.
So like,
let's get back to the bed,
but the handgun,
like do you try and get inside of 20
yards?
Like how close the chat?
Well,
it depends how good a shot you are.
Right.
But I mean,
they're effective at 50 yards,
but,
uh,
the accuracy is not so good,
but 20 yards is pretty good.
20 meters.
So,
um,
the,
so we're chasing this bear down right on
the borderline of Alaska and whatever
the Canadian provinces up there.
And,
um,
the,
I get within about 50,
40,
50 yards of him.
And,
uh,
then he turns around because he says,
why am I running?
You know,
the asked him said,
why am I running?
And he turns around and I hit him a
couple times with the four or five,
four and now I know.
So then he runs again.
And so I chased him some more and make a
long story short.
By the time I unloaded all five,
cause they don't need five shells.
He's,
he's,
he's wounded.
He would have died probably in an hour
or two hours,
but he's still dangerous.
So then I jumped on him and,
uh,
stabbed 70,
80 times.
Jesus Christ,
Dan 70 or 80 times,
I don't remember because the
adrenaline's pumping.
So it was so hard.
The,
the Hunter Guide said my arm looked like
a,
um,
a jackhammer.
It was going up and down so fast,
but I mean,
I'm just,
you know,
I'm dumb,
just jacked up.
And where he stabbed him,
I stabbed him in the chest,
around the head,
the neck in here.
I was trying to hit a main artery and
he's,
he trying to bite you on the big claws,
you know,
but I'm staying under the closet and
he's losing coordination.
He could've gotten me,
but he didn't.
He didn't.
Jesus Christ.
Well,
get up,
which is a brown bear or a black bear
brown.
But the better story is the Buffalo.
Now you,
Suzie,
how do you get a better story than you?
Maniacally homocide.
Nickel homicidally homicidally stabbing
a brown bear to death.
I don't know.
I went to the La Australia there.
You saw the movie Crocodile Dundee?
Yes,
I do.
Okay,
well there's a real crocodile dundee.
His name was barry leaves.
So I went down there to hunt with him in
Australia for 10 days and,
uh,
again with a handgun.
And um,
he said,
I said,
I want to take,
I want to get a big bowl,
a big bowl,
a water buffalo.
Yeah,
exactly.
And he said,
okay,
well we have to go into a certain part
of Australia up near Darwin,
up north.
And he said that,
um,
I can't promise you still going to be
there,
but there's a big pond about four or
five times as big as this room and he
should be there in the late afternoon
scratching his back on the roots
overhanging.
And so we got,
got there and we hiked in four or five
hours and he was there just like he said
he was going to be there and he said
that,
um,
uh,
you went,
um,
you know,
not just don't want to just shoot them
in the bag.
No,
I want,
I want him charging me.
So he says,
okay,
I want to say women.
You wanted him to charge you?
Yeah.
Why did you want that?
I never saw combat,
but why?
Why is that so important to you?
Like what is alleged is,
so just in your mind,
you needed to be not fulfilled.
Wow.
Life and death.
Yep.
It had to be like life and death combat.
Correct.
Wasn't with the enemy.
It was with some charging beats.
Correct.
Wow.
Okay.
So he throws pebbles.
Adam,
he spins around and he says he won't
come out this way because it's too far
for him to jump.
And he's not,
he can't jump that high.
Just like magic,
that Goddamn ball jump 15 feet in the
fucking air spun around and right at me.
So about where you are as he ran over me
and I fell back,
I shot once and I hit him through the
chin.
We're not as knows,
but it missed his brain.
He put one hook on my hip and that's why
I had to get a hip eventually and one
hook on my left knee.
So arguably that's why I have a left
knee.
So I felt like I had trained hit me.
So he keeps running.
I get up,
I'm dusted myself off.
So I've shot one out of five bullets,
so I see why I got it.
I'm going to kill this bastard.
So I'm chasing him in the jungle with a
blown out knee and a blown out hip.
Correct.
I'm chasing them in the jungle.
And the,
um,
the guide barry leaves is yellen.
Dan,
I can't hear them though,
cause I'm all pumped up.
Hey Dan.
Dan,
he's screaming at me so I get close to
him.
I shoot a couple of times more times
than I should have a couple more times,
and then the ball gets tired.
He spins around just like in the movies
and decided to charge from about that
wall and just as he got about to where
that chair is,
I fired again.
Click,
I'm empty.
Oh No.
And he falls down at my feet from the
other times I hit him,
Jesus Christ and so,
but with Barry leaves was yelling at me.
He says,
you're a fucking empty.
You're fucking empty.
He was telling me I had no more bullets
left.
What?
I couldn't hear that.
Now when you get in,
in,
in a contest,
martial arts does.
Do you go into automatic?
Yeah.
You have to think very little while
you're in there.
You're supposed to be,
I mean there you have,
when you separate a little bit,
you sometimes you have time to think
about what you're going to do,
but most of it is you're relying on your
training and your conditioning.
Well I hear you when you are announcing
a those the fields,
uh,
about,
there's seven guys that are really in
good condition that,
you know,
the animals are beasts and uh,
the,
it seems to me that that's one of the
telling things.
If you run out of gas in the second,
third and fourth round,
you're screwed.
Yeah.
Well there's different styles of
fighting too.
There's some guys who just,
they sprint and they can blow you out in
the first couple of rounds,
but if they get into the third,
fourth and fifth round,
they significantly diminished their
output.
And that's,
uh,
some,
some guys have strategies like to
weather the storm,
you just have to figure out a way to
whether a certain fight or storms and
then take them into the second and third
round.
I like,
there's a guy like Hector Lombard is a
famous,
a MMA fighter.
He was a champion and other
organizations,
he's just a scary,
scary guy.
And for one round he might be the
scariest motherfucker and the division,
he's terrifying.
He's built like a brick shit house.
He comes at you fast and hard,
but he's so muscular and so strong and
his output is so explosive and kinetic.
He's not like a rhythmic,
slow,
technical,
methodical fighter.
He's a sprinter.
And so after that initial sprint,
it's,
he's not the same in the second and
third rounds usually cause he win.
Sometimes he wins a lot.
I mean,
he's a world class fighter for sure.
The guys I liked with the Diaz brothers.
Oh yeah.
Well Duh.
They're appropriate.
They're the opposite.
They're guys who just,
they just come at you and they can throw
volume for days.
They don't ever get tired.
Those guys can go on and on and on and
on.
Not,
they break people with their pace.
Yeah.
And,
and the,
when he beat,
uh,
the older one,
I guess beat Mcgregor.
No,
the younger one gets nate.
Nate is the younger one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
That was a great fight.
It was a fun fight.
Second fight was fun too.
Yeah.
So you,
so from not having combat experience in
the war,
you had like this desire,
real combat experience.
You had this desire to put yourself in
danger and a test yourself?
Yeah,
I wanted to see if I was going to live
or die.
So that's why you decided the next way
to do this is to do it with a,
a water buffalo new,
you were talking earlier about mercenary
work.
Like what kind of,
what kind of mercenary?
In the early eighties,
I had the privilege of being mentored by
constantine sauce,
who was the chief executive of Onassis
shipping line,
the 60 year right hand man of Aristotle
Onassis.
He was one of my mentors.
And um,
the,
um,
he,
the Vatican,
the CIA,
a melded Marcos and a guy named
Talavera.
So mobile oil to CEO,
uh,
came up with an idea that they were
going to invade Haiti just like Clinton
did 12 years later.
Okay.
And um,
for all different reasons on acid is one
of the shipping of the oil,
a mobile,
one of the oil,
uh,
the Vatican one and more Catholics.
CIA wanted to have them not be a baby
doctor.
Volume communistic even with the
communist right at the,
at the near Florida.
And I don't know what the fuck I'm elder
was there for,
but you know,
she wasn't buying shoes or anything,
but she was there.
And,
uh,
I was put in charge of that project,
by,
uh,
Mr [inaudible] and,
the,
and we put together a mercenary army and
we had some of the great mercenaries,
a guy named Mike Williams,
one of the great mercenaries of the
seventies and eighties.
And just as we were going to launch the
attack in land with boots on the ground,
uh,
Cyrus Vance,
secretary of state pulled the plug on
the deal,
but I was going to come out of a
helicopter just like shorts nacre judge,
by the way,
you can't hold us.
Big Guns aren't,
you can't,
the way they do it at the too heavy.
But anyway,
I was going to be the first foot feet on
the ground and then when that thing fell
to shit,
I said,
well,
maybe I'm just not meant to see combat,
you know?
Wow.
So it was something that was really
important to you.
Was it important to you because you
didn't know how you would fare or
because you knew how you would fare and
you wanted to test yourself or you just
wanted to,
I was 100% positive.
I knew that I had balls and I wouldn't,
you know,
Wienie out.
But until you do it,
you don't know for sure.
Growing up as a kid and on the hood and
he'd been arrested five times and all
the trouble.
I got him up in the hood.
Yeah.
What Hood?
He still a did you really?
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
In fact,
we were just over there.
I like to go to the hood to three times
a year just to see it again.
And so I went from the Jonathan Club
where I'm a member to the hood and uh,
the,
uh,
is my same driver.
I've had many years.
And uh,
we took one of my mentees who's also
from the hood Cambodian kid because the
Cambodians drove the Mexicans out of my
portion of the hood.
And so I went to back to the hood and he
went to the same grammar school.
I did,
wrote a street.
He went to the same Catholic church I
went to.
Now for your audience,
nobody believes this.
But I used to teach catechism.
I used to teach Bible study because I
wanted to be a priest.
You wanted to be a priest when I was a
little kid.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
the,
it's hard to believe,
but I did,
but maybe all little Catholic boys when
they're 10,
12,
13 wanted to be priest.
Maybe not.
But I did.
So,
uh,
when,
um,
when I got in a lot of trouble when I
was in the fifth,
sixth grade,
I dropped an aquarium and it's on my
side.
I,
it's pointed a picture from the second
floor.
I dropped an aquarium on my teacher's
head from the second floor.
And if he hadn't moved six inches,
we wouldn't be sitting here.
I would have gone to San Quentin.
I would have gone to Juvi Bubba,
Bubba,
and I would've had a different life.
So he was then,
I only broke his own,
shattered his shoulder.
Oh fuck him up as Christ and I,
that's not the worst thing I did in
school.
I was expelled three times before I got
out of grammar school.
But yeah,
grammar school,
Grammar School.
What'd you do?
Well,
I did that to the teacher.
They expelled you for how long?
Uh,
three weeks.
And then you come back then another guy?
No,
I didn't say sorry.
Uh,
another guy,
another guy in the school.
Did you feel sorry?
No,
I don't,
I didn't try to kill,
I really didn't.
That wasn't in my mind old.
Were you at the time?
I was 11.
12.
So why were you doing that?
He pissed me off,
obviously.
I don't really remember why.
I know I dropped the guy damn aquarium
though.
That's a given.
So another guy I got in a fight with a
guy in and knocked him down and uh,
I was the biggest guy in grammar school.
I wasn't,
you know,
I remember that you were the biggest guy
in grammar school.
I was a Thomas Thomas to grammar school.
And uh,
so some other guy came up and I got in a
fight knocking him down and apparently
he broke his elbow when he fell down and
the kid says,
you broke my arm.
He broke my arm.
And then I did.
I went over and I,
I broke his arm and six places for real
after that.
Now you've got to meet her arm and so
fucking kid.
Yeah,
I guess it was.
So do you think that this was from
growing up in the hood,
just being in the wild dog eat dog
environment?
Yeah,
I'm positive.
It was.
Yeah.
And so that led you to really want to
test yourself in the military.
Correct.
And when you look back on all that stuff
and all that intense aggression and all
those thoughts,
how did you,
did you take anything out of that that
you carry with you as an older man?
Absolutely.
Uh,
well,
I'm a kinder,
gentler,
real nice guy.
I am.
Uh,
but I,
I've,
I've turned that aggression into a
success in business.
What about peace and calm?
Do you have that?
I don't meditate.
I don't do any of that stuff.
Um,
but do you feel good?
Do you feel like I feel like twisted
steel and panther ipis well,
I mean twisted steel and Panther Piss is
an odd combination of field.
Well that's a Texas oil field.
Uh,
yeah.
And I just visited a,
one of my buddies from the war who's
unfortunately got a agent orange.
Yeah.
You were telling me that like,
so what are the effects of agent?
However,
as you get older,
your immune system breaks down and the
Agent Orange that you had latent in your
system now starts to come out.
Like what does it,
how does it,
well,
I mean,
he's lost 40 pounds.
This guy,
I saw him pick up a core bet when we
were kids and now he has trouble getting
up steps.
So Agent Orange is some scary shit,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
Could,
it was an exfoliant,
right?
Or correctly it defoliant that they
sprayed on the jungle in Vietnam War.
All these soldiers who are down
there in it,
crazy,
crazy shit that they just experimented
on those kids.
Yeah.
And that's just,
you know,
again,
folks,
don't forget,
that was 50 years ago.
It wasn't that long ago at all.
We,
I mean every,
everything,
it's like I sat next to Mcnamara when he
was president of the World Bank who was
one of the fathers of the Vietnam War.
And,
uh,
he was a weird dude.
I mean,
uh,
and uh,
he,
uh,
he said that the world is going to end
in the,
uh,
La Apocalypse and it's going to be the
haves against the have nots someday.
He says,
hopefully you'll won't be around when
that happens.
Uh,
and,
um,
the,
uh,
he says there's certain problems on the
plant that are never going to get
solved.
And he talked about the Israeli middle
and he says,
yeah,
he says,
um,
they,
we have had,
um,
at that time too,
holy wars.
Uh,
and you could argue this is just an
extension of the holy war,
what's happening?
And he says,
we didn't work it out 700 and 780 and we
didn't work it out in an 1,118 and we're
not going to work it out this time.
And so he was kind of,
um,
a negative guy.
Class was half empty instead of half
full.
What do you think?
I don't think we're going to work it out
there either.
No,
I've been in partnership with the
Israeli government and I've been in
partnership with the Kuwaiti government,
the Yemen government and a couple others
there.
And,
um,
it's just a,
it's a bridge too far.
I just don't see it happening.
I just don't know.
Why is that?
Uh,
well,
I mean for the,
from the Muslim point of view,
uh,
and they have the right to practice
whatever religion they want,
but it's an eight,
ninth century religion in the 21st
century.
I mean,
there's a lot of stuff that's not
socially acceptable.
You talk about politically correct a lot
of the stuff they do,
it transcends being politically correct.
I mean,
um,
and I don't think that's going to
change.
I just don't,
uh,
I hope I'm wrong.
So you think that the way they,
like for instance,
where they treat women the way they
won't let women drive,
the way they make them worthy,
they're religious.
How do you say,
okay,
yeah,
the burgers.
Yeah.
Well,
so you think that that's just going to
stay the way it is forever.
In my lifetime.
In your lifetime,
maybe.
Maybe a hundred years maybe.
Sort of like comparing Christianity from
the inquisition to today.
Yeah.
Like so they need it needs to somehow or
another catch up.
Yeah.
And and maybe 500 years a,
well,
for the planet's sake,
I think we haven't been as aliens
haven't come to this planet because they
look at us,
we're all fucked up.
He's always saying,
yeah,
do you contemplate this
car with a glass of Scotch calling?
We're a fucking aliens here.
I want to shoot Ya.
Yeah.
I don't think they're interested in what
are we going to get?
What are they going to learn from us?
Well,
I would be absolutely fascinated if I
found a group of chimpanzees that had
figured out how to make fire with sticks
and we're building structures and we're
starting some sort of a,
an organized war against other,
uh,
I would be absolutely fascinated if they
had weapons and they were sneaking up on
these other chimps and using spears,
I'd be like,
Holy Shit,
look at this.
This is us a long time ago.
Well,
I would imagine that aliens would feel
the same way about us.
Well,
I mean,
except that there are probably a million
years advanced maybe,
or maybe a hundred years advanced.
Well,
if there are a hundred years advanced,
I think they would've come down and see,
maybe they're not ready yet.
Yeah,
well it'd be a hundred years from now.
We won't be ready to go to other
planets,
but maybe someone out there is just a
little bit more advanced than us now.
I,
the Elon Musk wants to die on Mars.
That mother fucker's ridiculous.
Okay.
He wants to die on Mars in an electric
car.
And the,
uh,
you know,
when the first electric car was Joe.
Yeah.
Long time ago.
It was in the early 1900 [inaudible]
1860s was it really?
Okay.
If we really wanted electric cars,
it was the first car for 2030 years ago,
and yet if we really wanted electric
cars,
don't you think we could have developed
them by now?
Well,
we definitely should have,
but the influence of the fossil fuel,
correct?
Yeah.
And do you know why Aramco is going
public?
The a a national oil company of Saudi
Arabia?
No.
Okay.
You're going to hear it first here.
Jesus can't believe they're selling 2%
of the company,
not because they need money,
because they've got all the money in the
world.
They want it because when you go public,
you have to have a reserve report.
The reserve report,
he's going to show how many barrels they
have proved producing,
proved unproved
and we've been guesstimating for years
and years and years that Aramco has got
a couple of hundred million barrels,
maybe three,
four,
500 million barrels,
billion barrels.
Excuse me.
That report's going to show they have
trillions of barrels and there's no
fucking way they're ever going to let
fracking,
electric cars or anything else when
they're out of their trillions of
barrels,
then they're going to let electric cars
come to pass.
So you think like all these oil crisis
warnings and all the talk about them
running out of oil and places is all
bullshit.
Yep.
A hundred percent hundred.
What do you think oil is?
Okay,
let me just back up a second.
And August,
2014 I was on a a not a show is
procedure.
This is yours,
but at some other guy show,
and I said that when oil was $120 a
barrel,
we will see $40 oil before we see $200
oil.
A bet.
Both of my testicles.
Oh strong.
Okay.
In February last year,
oil hit $26 a barrel.
Today's 48 wow.
Now there's a whole bunch of reasons
why.
I know that having done business in the
Middle East,
knowing Aramco has got hundreds of
trillions of barrels.
Knowing that when the king of Saudi
Arabia passed away about a year and a
half ago,
and his brother who's a considered not,
uh,
is bright as his brother,
half brother died and who hates
Americans allegedly,
and who is sick and tired of hearing
about fracking,
that we're going to end the frackers
forever.
And so they,
and there's no way,
eh,
see OPEC is great
except there's no accountability.
There's only two countries in the world
that actually I hear to OPEC,
Canada,
three countries,
the US and UK,
everybody else cheats.
How so they,
they,
they produce as much oil as they want.
So what is OPEC has regulations on how
much oil you can produce.
Correct.
And why did they have those regulations?
Because they kept the market.
He correct.
So they don't drive down the price of
the market.
So now what they're doing with fracking
is they're making oil in America so
readily available that the s what
they're doing in the Middle East is
dropping the price down low so that the
fracking is not worth doing.
And a barrel of oil at the wellhead from
a frack.
Well,
the cost is about 80 bucks a barrel.
Ah,
you just get it there and not to get it
in the pipeline,
not to get it to the refinery is not the
end doing that.
80 bucks a barrel.
So if they keep all between 40 and 60
for the next a hundred years,
well the frackers are fucked.
Yeah.
And
well,
how,
what do you,
how do you feel about fracking?
Because I've heard mixed stories about
fracking or mixed mixed reports and
mixed mixed opinions.
Some people believe that it's a good way
for us to be independent with our oil
and to break off from this whole weird
sort of crisis and this,
this,
uh,
situation that we have with the Middle
East and other people feel like it's
super dangerous.
And what we're doing is where
potentially poisoning water supplies,
we are creating earthquakes in some
place that's as stable as Oklahoma,
which was like seismically,
it was a nonentity,
like never had any issues with
earthquakes.
Now they have tons of earthquakes and
they're just constantly drilling into
the ground.
And who knows where the content,
well,
both,
both of those theories are correct,
both of the theories,
but I'm not a save the world kind of
guy.
What are you a slash and burn type of
now?
No,
not slash and burn.
But I believe that if there is a higher
power,
he helps those who help themselves.
So I mean,
uh,
I,
and it's convenient to think like that
though.
Well,
I think it is.
That's why I think that way.
But if he helps those that help
themselves,
wouldn't he not help people who had
poison the waters supply?
Well,
I mean,
that's an exaggeration.
It's not,
it's not poisoning
the water supply like,
uh,
like,
the protesters are saying,
but by the same token,
why frack?
When,
if my theory is correct about Saudi
Arabia having hundreds of trillions and
they're never going to,
you know,
they're never going to allow the fracked
oil to come to market.
Why do it right?
If they're never going a lot of correct.
Okay.
So the fracked oil,
what are they doing with it right now?
Well,
right now,
uh,
fracking is down like 70 or 80%.
It is.
Yes,
it is.
Um,
why is it down?
Because the price of oil.
Yeah,
exactly.
It has nothing to do with environmental
concerns.
No,
I mean it's just like I'm,
Obama didn't want the pipeline because
of environment concerns,
Dakota access pipeline,
but it all started during his watch.
Yeah,
I understand that.
But now trump has says that you can have
the pipeline because he's looked at the
same studies that I've looked at and
it's all online on Google is that there
is this much,
the United States and the environmental
things may be hurting is this much in
the United States.
So you're talking,
you made your,
spread your arms up very wide for people
listening.
Okay.
And then when you said the about an
environmental concerns,
you put it very small.
Correct.
But isn't it something that if we could
avoid those very small environmental
disasters,
so it was very small environmental
they're going to impact that area for
thousands of years.
Correct.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a significant issue.
I'm sure it is.
But I mean,
there's more than that.
You know,
there's the,
the one side of an argument,
the other side of the argument and then
somewhere in between is the truth.
I mean,
the truth lies.
But do you think that's the only way for
us to prosper is to put those areas in
danger?
I mean,
if you,
if you say that it,
it,
there is a potentially a,
there's a potential for an environmental
disaster that could affect that area for
thousands of years.
Take that risk for financial gain.
No,
not from to Fresno.
I'm not saying for financial gain.
It's not a financial,
you know,
of course it's a financial gain.
I was in the oil business for 20 years
now,
allegedly,
where I made my fortune,
but the allegedly,
allegedly,
yeah,
I've got other things very successfully,
but that's the one that they talk about.
I turned $800 into $500 million in eight
years.
And so forevermore I'm an oil man.
Okay.
But I did,
I've created 50 billion since then.
So I mean,
what's more important to 50 billion to
the 500 million?
So I got it.
Okay,
okay.
But the,
the,
the fact is that
politically,
whoever gets in office,
and right now we have trump and he's
backed by the Senate and the congress,
et Cetera.
Um,
it has promised to be like an
isolationist,
more or less.
He's not interested in the wards around.
And I'm not saying that's right or
wrong,
I'm just saying that's his position.
And a majority of the electoral votes
got him elected.
Not The popular vote,
but electoral votes.
Okay?
So,
uh,
the,
but whether the United States of America
is a ruining parts of it,
500 years from now,
there'll be ruined a while whilst
important.
It is not the overriding,
um,
energy,
pun intended,
uh,
of what we should be thinking about.
What we should be thinking about is
doing away with war,
you know,
uh,
living,
happily,
you know,
and I ain't even,
I believe that and I'm,
and I'm an aggressive guy,
but that model hasn't worked.
Why is that?
Well,
a,
why were,
there's still wars?
Well,
I mean,
when you talk about the Iraq war and
talk about the Afghanistan war,
those are the longest wars we've engaged
in the United States.
And we didn't have to be there.
Right?
No,
I understand that.
But how are we going to keep people
elected?
Those people,
they put us there.
Right?
Just like the people elected trump to
put him there,
just like they elected Clinton to put
him there.
Right.
And we still,
we're still in wars.
Right.
But Clinton didn't do it.
I mean this was all post nine 11 and
there were,
there was obviously some military
actions that were involved when Clinton
was in office,
but when Bill Clinton was president,
it was one of the most peaceful times in
the history of this country.
When you agree.
Um,
he took out a Haiti,
he followed up on the Dan Pena plan to
take out Haiti.
That was the Dan Pena Plan.
The CIA.
Dan Penn.
Your trademark.
Yes.
Well,
I can coin it now,
but I mean,
don't you think that in terms of like if
you compare pre,
uh,
Bush,
you know,
when,
when nine 11 happened from then on,
we've been in this perpetual state of
war,
but during the entire eight years of
Clinton was in office,
although there were some military
actions,
one of the more peaceful times,
they probably was.
You're probably right.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
there wasn't as much worry as a risk
today.
Like today,
it seems like there's threats of
terrorism.
We're worried about North Korea
instability all around the globe.
I went to,
here's something else for the first on
your program.
Who Do you think killed the president's
half brother of North Korea?
Didn't they like hire some people?
They thought it was a prank.
Well,
that's what the story is.
Oh,
was a different story.
Yeah,
no,
true.
That the,
well,
the North Koreans think that the South
Koreans did it right.
I think that USA CIA did it well.
I thought the North Koreans thought that
the s the brother did it,
that Kim Jong Ooh.
And did it too.
Yeah.
Because the brother was kind of sneaked
to send a message to North Korea.
Really?
What kind of messages that,
I mean that don't,
don't fuck with us.
Oh,
it seems like they could do a better job
of sending that message.
Well,
I mean,
they killed him I guess,
but who is he?
He wasn't even in the,
no,
but I mean they believe you can kill the
half-brother.
The president can kill the president.
Well that will probably be a better
idea.
But if they did do that,
don't you think it would just create a
vacuum?
Like the same thing that happened and I
don't really,
I don't read enough books to know that I
don't read any books on and Libya,
but I've watched a lot of documentaries
on that whole Kadafi situation.
That's a complete cluster fuck.
Well,
I mean the United States government has
been doing that for a hundred years,
where they back the government,
it turned out to be a crooked
government.
So then they got to go take all the
backing away from him and then avoid
[inaudible] is created.
And then the guys,
they come in or worse,
yeah.
What's going on in their rack,
right?
Yeah.
We've been doing that for them.
And then,
and,
but,
but what's happening in Libya and Libya
is a basically a failed state.
It's a scary,
scary place right now.
And,
uh,
if you talk to people that were there
pre,
uh,
pre Kadafi or during Qaddafi's
administration,
now they're like,
it's way safer then when Kadafi was
running things.
Obviously if you were a,
an enemy of Kadafi,
it wasn't safe for you.
He was all a brutal dictator.
But the,
the business of running countries,
especially running countries all around
the world is a horrible,
horrible,
messy business.
You know,
Messi,
brutal evil business.
It's always underestimated.
And I'm,
one of my favorite sayings is never
underestimate how wrong you can be.
And,
uh,
the,
and we always seem to underestimate it.
Um,
and um,
I don't think that's going to change.
Is it?
Right?
We're going to get better.
I mean,
we've gotten better.
We've gotten better.
I mean since caveman,
since that,
since that chimpanzee to learn how to
use a rock.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Well we've gotten better.
I mean,
but,
uh,
we've been getting better for 40,000
years and the planet's been alive for
13.8 billion years,
but we've only had Google for like 20 Oh
yeah.
Well that,
well,
I'm,
I'm not such a proponent of that Google
is going to change the world,
but I don't think so.
No,
I'd Ha,
well,
not like the millennials think or the,
or maybe,
I don't know.
I'm a generation X.
I guess.
It's funny,
that whole generation thing,
we get labels.
I think there's a real possibility that
information,
and I think there's a lot of,
there's some battles going on right now
with information where people trying to
figure out how it should affect things
and what it should affect and,
and what,
what kind of an impact it's ultimately
going to have in our culture.
But I think it's having a massive
impact.
And I think it's hard for us to,
yeah,
which is why I said Google,
but google meaning the ability to search
things,
you know,
there's going be a big access to
information through those portals dated
with instant information.
Yeah.
I mean,
what took guys years,
the research for a phd paper can be now
researched in days,
weeks or that,
yeah,
it's a magical time when it comes to
that.
And I feel like that if anything is
gonna change foreign countries quicker
than any other kind of change because I
feel like just having the access to the
information that things are different or
the parts of the world that people are
thinking differently than they ever
thought before,
that there's more understanding about
people that we have more in common than
we do.
Then this idea that countries are
against each other,
the countries are there consistent of
people that don't even know each other
for the most part.
And we're supposed to be against some
other people that we don't know.
And then some of the part of the world.
Well,
why is it then,
um,
tenement square in,
in,
uh,
Beijing 30,
whatever years ago it was,
uh,
when we were in China,
not too long ago as it gets to the
government,
uh,
most kids don't even know that that
happened.
Yeah.
Because they have google.
Okay.
Same in Russia.
Uh,
salmon countries in South America.
Now getting back to why,
uh,
the,
the oil,
uh,
hydrocarbons are so important.
Russia's got a oil driven economy.
Now a good,
many of the countries in South America
have oil driven economies.
Now Canada has an old driven economy.
Now,
uh,
the U K arguably has an old driven
economy,
not visa vi the North Sea.
Okay.
Uh,
the u s it doesn't really have an old
driven economy,
but it has a big,
big part of what happens now when you
are making loans from financial
institutions at a hundred,
$120 oil with projections because some
dip Shit Mba did a spreadsheet on them,
uh,
to a $200 oil and you make loans.
And now all those loans are underwater,
pun intended for the offshore stuff.
So is that what happened?
They made loans based on the prediction
that it would continue to go up.
So some sort of a universal growth or
continual growth paradigm,
but anybody that's from the business,
like I was knew that that was horseshit.
Why did they think that unlimited growth
in oil was going to happen and it was
going to get to $200 a bottle if guys
are barrel rather if guys like you
thought it was horse shit because a
whole other generation has come up,
it didn't suffer.
The last oral decline that lasts oil
decline was w is the early eighties
through the mid eighties.
When oil went from $40 a barrel.
If they $6 a barrel and then went back
up to $35 a barrel,
all those guys are either dead in jail
or retired.
Okay.
And now they've got young guys who
learned something in a book.
I went to good schools and know how to
do spreadsheets,
et Cetera,
but they don't have the experience.
And,
uh,
the,
you know,
we have tons and tons of information but
we'll,
we don't have running a lot of the
companies is tons and tons of
experience.
We have a lot of dots,
but we don't have the people that have
connected the dots now to connect the
dots to find out how much the Middle
East actually has in barrels of oil is
trillions of bows.
Well,
how would one do that?
is this public information like what
you're saying?
Most people don't know.
They don't know.
Well,
because I was partners with Kuwaiti
government for seven years.
I used to be their fair haired boy for
investment.
Uh,
and I,
you could,
you a fair haired boy,
fair haired boy.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
A fair haired boy means that I was their
favorite.
That's a what?
A weird expression and a fair haired
boy.
I,
fair haired.
I want black hair.
Right?
Okay.
I have blue eyes.
I'm fairing my complexion.
Got It.
Okay.
That's what I get it.
It's,
it's weird.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and um,
I think it's very surprising and Aramco
is going to go public with the numbers
because it's been one of the great big
secrets of all time and the energy
business.
They're going public with the numbers to
discourage further frack.
Correct.
So they're going to say,
look,
we,
we would rather have 100% of this thing
at half the price.
Correct.
Then lose it all.
And the um,
most of the ultra alternative energy
deals,
the in the United States in the UK are
funded by grants,
government programs that fail.
I mean,
they don't make you,
they don't make any money,
but when you stopped doing that,
the average,
the average cost for a barrel of oil,
not fracking in this country,
uh,
is about 45,
50 bucks a barrel.
Who right at the break even to bring it
up to the wellhead now.
Okay.
In the Middle East,
taking all of them in into account,
it's about three bucks,
a berry dollars a barrel,
a couple of the countries less than a
buck flow.
How the fuck can they do then?
Because the oil is right there here.
[inaudible] and they found oil.
They were living in tents as better wins
and they were looking for water cause
they'd be dead.
Now if they hadn't found water a hundred
years ago,
they'd all be dead.
But they,
they didn't need the water cause they
got the oil that they paid to take to
make the water drinkable.
D salient.
Incorrect.
That's the word I was looking for.
Yeah.
So this,
this is,
that's an amazing thing.
So why is Exxon bothering to drill in
the Gulf coast?
Because hope springs eternal.
So they want to plan for the future.
Correct.
I drilled in the Gulf coast,
um,
when I was winning a big oil company,
uh,
and the,
and there's two parts of the Gulf coast.
There's the shelf,
which is a 600 feet deep.
And then there's beyond the shelf,
which is like 10,000 feet.
And that's big,
big money to do all those tests.
Wells,
uh,
and,
the big guys like Exxon are looking for
elephants.
They're looking for the big,
big reserves,
a smaller independence like I was was
looking for a,
you know,
the smaller reserves.
No want to Exxon goes and looks for the
big reserves to what kind of equipment
did they use to dick to decide where the
oil is?
Well,
uh,
an offshore drilling rig will cost
between a in the shallow at 25 to 40
million and in the deep,
uh,
75 to 250 million for just the rig.
The thing.
So how do they know where the oil,
so they have geologists,
which you're like,
ah,
this is a personal point of view.
Geologists.
Geophysicist.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're better off with a psychic.
So they basically know there's a shit
load of oil out there somewhere.
Drilling now what is oil?
Explain to me what is oil?
I read a book a long time ago.
The confused the fuck out of me.
It was called black gold stranglehold
and know if you've heard about it.
I've heard of it.
I never read it.
It was a book that was saying that oil
is not fossil fuels and then it's not
what people think it is,
but it's actually a renewal process that
the earth creates this oil and that
wells go dry.
And then if you leave them alone for a
while,
they build up with the oil.
Again,
not why they,
that's the theory.
But nobody's ever left the well alone
alone long enough to find out if that's
true or not.
Ah,
so we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of years.
They're not talking about 40 years.
So no,
but wells also this guy,
it might be,
it seemed like a wacky book.
It was one of those books.
I was reading of your word,
the holographic universe.
No,
it's another book.
Quick halfway in the book.
I'm like,
what the fuck am I reading?
This is a goofy ass book.
It's just too much goofiness in it.
But that Black Gold's triangle hold,
I wanted to talk to a real oil man about
this.
So oil is created by what things dying
deteriorating from 40,
50,
a hundred million years ago.
Uh,
and they sit under the ground and they a
form hydrocarbons,
uh,
two different kinds of hydrocarbons.
Either that's a gas and oil and uh,
and when the,
when it comes up that comes up one pipe
and there's a separator.
Sometimes you just have a pure oil
wells.
Sometimes you have it,
a pure gas well,
but mostly you have a mix.
So there's a separator.
It's a unit that is a,
uh,
engineers,
a wet dream at the top that separates
all this.
Then it's put into a pipeline and taken
to a refinery or it's put into a truck
and taken to a refinery.
Uh,
and some of the,
um,
the,
the distillate,
the actual or oil,
it's a,
depending on the gravity can go straight
into a car.
I mean,
that's how pure realist,
yeah.
And doesn't have to be refined.
Of course the refiners don't like those
kind of wells because then they,
what is it when it's,
when you don't have to refine it?
I mean,
it has been sat under the ground,
the oil,
the less time it's been under the
ground.
So if you've got moral that's been there
40 million years,
it will look like kerosene.
If you've got an oil that it's only been
there 10 million years,
it look a black and gunky.
Oh,
that's fascinating.
Now it's,
we used to call it dead dinosaurs,
but it's not really animal matter as
much as it is plant matter.
Is that true plant?
Yeah,
mostly planning on,
yeah.
So it's just a teary or rating leaves
and trees and things along those lines.
And then it's slowly but surely over
millions of years becomes oil.
What a weird thing to power our world
on.
Well,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's been around a long time,
but if we really wanted to electric
batteries,
we've had those 40 years longer than
we've had a gasoline cars.
What are your feelings on solar solar?
Um,
you probably don't know this,
but for every square foot on the earth,
the sun,
natural sun with no nothing,
uh,
advancing the Sun's light gives between
10 and 13,000 times more energy than the
planet needs.
10 to 13,000 for every square foot just
from the sun.
Whoa.
Wait a minute.
Hold on,
let me,
let me sort that out.
So what you mean is if you put solar
panels on every square foot,
you'd have 10 to 13 times more than the
planet needs.
Yes.
Einstein.
Correct.
But you wouldn't really put solar powers
over the whole correct planet.
So in order to be able to power a city,
what would you have to do?
Well,
I mean the city,
like let's say,
um,
[inaudible] alley.
How dare you call me Einstein.
Okay.
Uh,
the valley,
right.
Okay.
You need solar panels that would cover
from,
um,
downtown Los Angeles to
San Diego,
Jesus Christ.
And that's under current solar
technologies.
It's gotten much less expensive to do
that,
right?
Because then you've got to sell the
stuff into the grid.
The grid,
meaning the power thing,
like a scent.
Nuts.
What's the power thing up here?
Uh,
whatever the power company electric
company is.
So you sell into the grid and they will
tell you,
um,
when the government was giving
subsidies,
they were paying like 18 to 20 cents per
kilowatt.
Now they're paying two to 3 cents.
So people invested,
schmucks,
banks lend out Shannon's schmucks,
lend out 10 hundreds of billions of
dollars to the solar guys because at the
13 to 18 cents a megawatt and then
supply,
then we had too much supply because
everybody's doing it and drove down the
price.
And so now these poor bastards that
started these solar deals,
uh,
15,
20 years ago,
can't make any money.
So they can't pay off their debt.
The guys that benefit the most from
solar or the farmers that own the land,
that lease to the solar companies.
So it's another one of those unlimited
growth things where they felt like it
was 10 cents back then per kilowatt,
it's eventually going to be 20 and 30.
They kept thought it was going to go up
instead it went down.
And why did it go down?
Because oversupply,
because everybody gets on a a good thing
and then they make it bad.
But when you say you sell it back to the
grid,
there's also ways to do it.
To be off the grid,
right.
Craft a different system.
Yeah.
There are.
And a lot of,
uh,
you know,
very bright guy put together a tax
incentive deals,
uh,
in the Britain they called schemes,
that,
uh,
you know,
took advantage of the system.
Uh,
right now in Germany for example,
um,
Germany has a 20,
25 year contracts and the government
wasn't any smarter.
They gave you a 25 year contract at a
guarantee 11 cents.
Okay.
Now into the grid,
it's only 3 cents.
So they've got to pay you off and it was
between three and 11 and uh,
contract's up.
And then once it's up,
everybody's screwed.
Everybody,
you know,
everybody's screwed.
Wow.
Now,
do you think that it's a viable way to
power a city?
Yeah,
it is.
It is,
but I think it's a mix.
You need a mix really not,
you know,
not just solar undercurrent,
technological solar,
wind and a hydrocarbons.
Yeah.
We were in,
some were filming something for fear
factor wants and they had one of those,
a windmill farms.
It was the craziest thing ever.
It was like,
like a bunch of robots that were up on
this hill.
Correct.
We're spinning around and was like,
you're getting there getting electricity
from these wind robots.
Like how fucking weird is this?
And each one of those deals costs
roughly speaking of $1 million.
Wow.
Each one,
uh,
and uh,
the technology,
uh,
has,
has come a long,
long way and the 30 or 40 years that
they've had those wind when deals,
but
supposedly the wind currents don't
change [inaudible] wrong,
wrong.
They do change.
Okay.
And so you've built a hundred of these
windmills facing a certain way.
Right.
Okay.
And then the wind changes for whatever
reason.
Now I know the thing you're going to
hear first.
Uh,
in 2011,
my wife and I,
we had our bows,
we knew it at the South Pole magnetic
south pole.
We went to be married down and they have
a huge $500 million scientific research
lab,
most of which is paid for by the United
States government.
So we're down there and we're talking to
all the goofball scientists around in
shorts,
tee shirts and flip flops.
And it's 40 below zero.
Okay.
Cause it sun never goes down.
This was December.
Uh,
and so they're giving us a presentation
and they're bringing out these cores of
ice cores of ice and they get to the
second or third corps and then he says,
this core is 55,000 years old.
And of course I'm a,
how do you know that?
Anyway,
they explained and he said,
I'm 13,000 years ago.
This was the temperature of 14,050 5,000
years ago.
It was two degrees warmer Celsius than
it is today.
And then you go stop 55,000 years ago.
It was two degrees warmer than it is
today,
right?
And I said,
what about global warming?
Okay,
simultaneously all 10 and start
laughing.
All 10 phds from Mit,
Caltech,
snapper started laughing when they laugh
because global warming is a joke.
How's global warming a joke?
I'm just telling you what they said.
It was warmer.
Two degrees Celsius,
but that's a 55,000 years ago.
Well,
if you go back 65 million years ago is
considerably warmer than I understand
that.
But what they were saying is that it's
cyclical,
right?
But I don't think that's the argument.
The argument is whether or not we're
contributing to this cyclical.
I'm sure we are.
Yeah.
But I mean,
if we wait 10,000 years,
there won't be any global warming.
It'll go back to cold.
Correct.
And the people,
you're descendants,
my descendants,
if they're around 10,000 years from now,
we'll read about that.
Who are those guys have believed in
global warming.
So you think that people are being
hysterical about a natural cycle that we
probably are.
We're,
we're probably helping it along.
We're helping it along,
but it's a natural cycle,
but it's going to come back around
anyway.
Another point,
if global warming,
we're for real,
I mean,
real,
real that's going to happen is he's
going to have next 20,
30 years.
Okay.
Florida,
most of Central America,
a whole bunch of the part of the world
is going to be gone because there'll be
underwater,
right?
Depending on,
you know,
the most,
uh,
severe,
it's 30 meters of water.
That's a hundred feet.
The less severe is 10 meters of water.
30 feet.
Okay.
If that were the case and you were
building condominiums in Fort
Lauderdale,
Florida,
there should be a disclaimer in the
prospectus.
Yeah,
there should be a disclaimer.
The next big way,
the class action lawsuits,
if global warming happens in the next 20
to 50 years,
is going to be the disclaimers that were
not written in an investment perspective
for condominiums,
buildings everywhere.
Manhattan's gone,
you know London has gone well,
that's only under severe forecast,
right?
Severe forecasts.
The best forecast is it's going to be 10
meters,
10 meters.
We'll just dirty feet.
That's the best forecasts,
the best forecasts over how many years?
A 50 so you don't,
you don't think that's going to happen?
I'm not likely to be here 50 years from
now,
so I had a pretty good dude if they keep
replacing shit.
Yeah.
Well I'm pretty good.
My,
my goal is 101
yeah,
right now 70 I'll be 72 and a few weeks.
You look great.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Got a lot of pep to you now.
So,
but I,
I,
I'm happy cause I'm enjoying doing what
I do.
Do you realize 87% Gallup poll came out
last year.
It's at 87% of the people on the planet
or unhappy with what their life is all
about now on have the and 10% in
addition to that,
87 to 97 hate what they do.
A little.
So that leaves 3% of the planet.
Enjoy what they do.
And you're one of 3%.
Fuck,
I'm one of the 100000000th of a percent.
Uh,
I'm so happy.
I don't know whether to shit or go
blind.
Well,
you shouldn't do the second part.
Every little behind a chair.
Don't go blind.
No,
no,
I don't think that makes you happier.
Well,
they're going to,
they're going to figure out how to give
me new eyes.
They are,
do you think they're gonna figure out
how to give you new eyes or do you think
they're going to figure out how to shoot
some stem cells in your eyes or Ridgeway
and I'm uh,
I want to hear after the program about
the stem cells in Vegas.
Yeah.
They've got a lot of crazy shit going
on.
They're doing discs now.
They,
uh,
are just starting,
talked to Dr. Davidson from the UFC and
they're beginning trials.
I think they were going to do it this
Monday,
so past Monday,
a couple of days ago where they're going
to shoot stem cells directly into discs
of people with degenerative disc disease
where their discs are shrinking because
the compression of the spine and you
know,
just overall life and wearing down,
they're going to be able to regenerate
this tissue.
Yeah.
Well,
what's a story about,
I read a couple of days ago,
um,
a transgender guy broke the eye socket
of a girl in an MMA fight.
I don't know about that.
Is that a recent,
the last 48 hours to know about that.
Okay.
And they're complaining because it's not
really a girl,
it's a guy and he was just overpowered
and he just,
no,
I've never heard of a broken eye socket.
And when those guys sockets are really
common,
oh,
the,
okay.
I didn't know that.
And can I soccer?
It's broken.
Orbitals very,
very common.
If you get punched or kicked or elbowed
really hard in the eyeball,
which sounds horrible to people,
but uh,
you get a blowout fracture where you
actually blow out the bone in the back
of the eyeball.
So they have to literally take your eye
out and they have to go behind it.
Repair usually at that,
sometimes they have to put like a little
plate or something that puts the bone
back together in the back of your eye,
put your eye back in.
And sometimes when guys do get those
kind of orbital fractures,
they have these weird eyes like the one
I that like pokes forward more than the
other eyes.
It looks weird.
Very Dangerous Sport,
very dangerous sport,
you know,
it's just obviously it's a combat sport.
Kind of smash each other.
Yeah,
I've been pretty vocal about,
there was a,
a a pretty famous case of a guy who had
been a guy for 30 years,
became a woman for two years,
you know,
or you know,
went transgender,
whatever you want to call it.
And started fighting MMA and wasn't
telling these women that she used to be
a man for 30 fucking years and I was
like,
well that's crazy.
Like if you tell people and they still
want to fight,
that's fine.
I think you should be able do whatever
you want to do.
Just like I think you should be able to
ride a bull.
I,
you know I support your right to ride a
bull.
You want to ride a bull.
I'm not telling you you shouldn't do it
because I don't,
where the fuck am I to tell you they
shouldn't jump out of buildings and a
and skydive or jump out of planes rather
or a jump off cliffs with one of those
wingsuits like my friend Andy does you.
You should.
You should be able do whatever you want
to do as long as you're informed,
but this idea that it's not something
that you need to tell the other person
about because now you're a woman.
I say that's bullshit.
You're a biologically a man.
You were born a man,
you have an x,
y chromosome.
You have all sorts of mechanical
advantages.
You have different bone structure,
it's not the fucking same.
And if these people want to continue
this crazy narrative that once you
decide that you identify with being a
woman,
he should be able to compete as a woman.
It's fucking crazy.
I mean,
I'm sure you saw what happened with that
kid in high school.
There was a kid in high school.
Yeah.
She,
she wanted to be a boy and so they
started giving her testosterone
treatments,
but she still has to compete as a girl
in wrestling while she's transitioning
to being a boy.
So they giving her these testosterone
treatments and she's just mauling these
girls.
Yeah.
It's just not fair.
What happened to the,
uh,
the girl,
it's not her fault,
by the way,
that kid,
that's the fucking,
the people that live there want her to
compete as a girl.
And if that's the case,
you shouldn't allow her to be competing,
wants to taking testosterone.
It's real simple.
And if she wants to compete as a boy
letter,
compete as a boy,
or I let him compete as a boy.
In your opinion,
what happened to the young girl?
That was Ronda Rousey.
Yes.
The Olympian girl that you know,
all of a sudden went from the penthouse
to the Shit House.
Lot of things.
It's a long,
long story.
I was a big sign over her amazing judo
practitioner,
um,
and dominant like no one else ever in
women's mma up to that point.
It's in the UFC at least.
But there was some holes in her approach
that were exposed by Holly Holm.
The point in the doctor out girl head
kicked her.
Holly had the perfect style to deal with
Rhonda style.
She's really strong,
she's fast,
she's amazing athlete and she is an
outstanding striker and so ron does
thing was to charge at you like a
fucking bull.
And Holly just played the Matador,
brilliantly caught her,
lit her up while she was coming in and
then eventually had kicked her and
stopped her.
Once you get knocked out like that,
first of all,
she was very,
very confident while she was the
champion.
And some people would say arrogant.
And because of that,
there's all these people that are
waiting for you to fall.
There's a lot of people out there that
don't have much confidence and when they
see someone who's out there who's got a
lot of confidence,
it's very compelling.
Like a floyd mayweather or Latin conor
mcgregor,
their,
their confidence is incredibly
compelling.
Like you,
you want to be near them.
But those people,
when that person loses,
they're the first ones to attack.
They're like,
yeah,
you fucking loser.
I knew you're a loser.
Like you go to Ronda Rousey's a
instagram page and read the comments
under her pictures.
It's ruthless.
Some fucking assholes.
This assholes.
And I guarantee you all those people are
severely unaccomplished or really young,
either young kids that don't understand
what they're doing.
They just have this opportunity to be
able to talk shit or they're a bunch of
fucking losers.
And they're finding this opportunity to
shit on someone who was this incredible
bright,
shining star that fizzled out.
So she lost to Holly Holm and then she
came back in a far worst matchup against
Amanda Nunez.
And I thought Nunez before Holly Holm
beat or I thought Nunez was the most
dangerous matchup for cause.
Amanda Nunez is a Brazilian Jujitsu
black belt and she has heavy,
heavy hands.
He's a dangerous striker and I was like
Ron is going to have to close the
distance or to grab her and take her to
the ground.
And when she does it's still fucking
picnic because Amanda Nunez is nasty on
the ground.
And then getting close to her,
she's got knockout power with her hands.
I'm like this is a terrible,
terrible matchup.
And it turned out to be right because
she got knocked down 48 seconds and the
rematch.
But what she should've done is revamp or
camp or not fight,
revamp re go to one of the masters.
There's a few masters of mixed martial
arts in this world is for Rasa Hobby and
Matt Hume and Duke Roufus is a few of
these striking mixed martial arts
masters and you have to go to them,
you have to go to them and you have to
like submit yourself and say look,
let's fix this.
Let's fix whatever I'm doing.
And let's see if we can take this to the
next level because the sport evolved and
the sport pastor by like she was at the
very top,
but if you build it,
it's like that field of dreams movie,
you build it,
they will come.
And when she built the women's Bantam
Weight Division and became this dominant
force and stopped all these people and
looked invincible,
all those women were coming up below her
and they were,
they were getting better and they were
evolving and they were like the rest of
mma,
they were reaching this incredibly high
level.
Where's the women's MMA movement?
And then in the early days,
you know,
three,
four years ago,
if you watched women's mma,
this skill level was nowhere near
commensurate with the men skill level,
like demand skill level at the three,
four years ago.
They're better today but only a little
bit better.
But the women are way better today than
they were because it's a new thing.
It's like 1997 for mixed martial arts
from men.
That's what like three or four years ago
it was,
but now the women have essentially
pretty much caught up or close to it.
There's very high level striking,
very high level submissions,
very high level fluid overall mixed
martial arts games that you're seeing in
the women's division and Rhonda in a lot
of ways,
a spectacular,
she was,
had a very limited approach.
She didn't kick,
she punched,
but she wasn't necessarily like the most
brutal knockout puncher and she wasn't
necessarily the most skillful boxer.
She didn't really have a tremendous
amount of experience.
What she had was incredible athleticism,
a worldclass mindset.
She was a world class athlete,
you know,
she's a former Olympian and outstanding
judo.
Her judo and our arm bars are amongst
the best in the world.
I'm sure it transitions the way she
attacks and attacks and tax and set
things up.
She's phenomenally talented and you
know,
really accomplished in judo.
But when you want to be a world mixed
martial arts champion at the highest
level of the game,
now you have to be great at everything.
There's people like Demetrius mighty
mouse Johnson I think is the best
fighter in the world.
He's amazing.
Yeah,
that guy's great at everything and
that's why he's the best cause you don't
know what the fuck he's going to do.
You don't know if he's going to kick you
or knee you or take you down or strangle
you or,
or,
or elbow you.
And he's just got so many options and
he's coming at you from all different
directions and he never gets tired.
He's,
he's the total full package.
We don't have a demetrius mighty mouse,
Johnson and women's mma yet,
but it's common.
It's common.
And Brian does not that,
you know,
Rhonda is more like maybe like a
chocolate dell or one of the early
pioneers of men's mma.
Super talented,
really fun to watch,
but perhaps limited in their approach.
I used to enjoy,
well,
I enjoy mighty mouse.
Now that you mentioned you met,
he's incredible.
He's incredible.
You know,
there's a,
there's so many of them now.
I mean it's just this sport is just
exploding and it's exploding with towels
and changed his,
they sold well.
It has a little bit,
it's trying to like refine itself I
think.
But the guys who sold it or the guys who
bought it rather,
um,
you know,
they're savvy,
intelligent dudes who are trying to do
it their way and there's going to be
some bumps along the way.
There's Ma,
they've made a lot of changes and
they're trying to do some things
differently.
And some of the things I agree with,
like now I have a three man booth,
like it's me and a fighter and then the
play by play commentator,
which we've done a couple of times.
So I think is really good.
I like it.
And I'm there.
They've got a lot of match ups that have
fallen through unfortunately because of
weight cut issues and a bunch of other
stuff.
So it's a tough business man.
I wouldn't want to be a promoter.
It's a,
what I do is easy.
I just show up and things are happening.
I talk about the things that are
happening.
It's not a lot,
you know,
I don't have to do a lot of work to get
there.
You know,
I just kind of get there and then I
watch and I talk about the fights.
That promoting angle of it is
unbelievably brutal.
You have to rely on so many people to do
their job.
So many people that have their shit
together,
you've got to rely on these crazy
impulsive maniacs known as MMA fighters.
They get their weight in order and to,
to have their camp go through without
severely injuring themselves and to do
things smartly and intelligently and
conservatively so that they can show up
for the dance and be able to perform at
their best.
It's,
you know,
it's,
you're asking a lot of,
a lot of different people and most of
them come through.
You know,
most fighters are incredibly
professional.
Uh,
but some of them don't like that.
Habib number,
madoff,
Tony Ferguson fight that fell through a
couple of weeks ago or last week.
Horrible.
Just devastating that were,
you know,
we were all ready for that fight.
And then in the day of the fight,
how he can't make it the day of the
weigh ins,
rather he can't make the weight and they
send him to the hospital.
So those kinds of things do happen.
These guys that are running it now,
the wme guys,
you know,
they're smart as hell.
So we'll just see.
They'll figure it out.
That's what I think.
I think they'll,
he'll take a little while.
It'll be,
there'll be a little bit of trial and
error.
Just understandable.
I mean,
they're going to,
they spent 4 billion on the UFC.
They're going to want it run it their
way.
I get that.
It's incredible investment.
I don't know how the fuck they're going
to make that money back.
You're a,
you're a smart financial guy.
How the hell they make that money back?
Oh,
Jesus.
Dan Pena.
Why didn't you do that?
Is Not likely.
No.
Uh,
the way I would do it is a,
I would take it public.
Oh,
it was that,
I need to know where you heard it here
first on Joe Show,
take it public and they that they can
make 50% on their money in a week.
I mean a week after they take it public
because the uh,
the average investor pays up to much,
they pay up high multiples.
And the difference between a non a
liquid investment and a liquid
investment,
the multiples are normally 50 to a
hundred percent higher.
Just asked me talk Chinese if he's,
if,
let's just say they bought it at 20
times earnings.
Okay.
Forbidden Equated to 20 times earnings,
right?
20 Times per annual.
Yeah,
that's correct.
So,
uh,
they take it public and the,
the investment public,
the schmucks that buy stocks on the New
York Stock Exchange,
we'll give you 40 times.
They will.
Yes.
While they do that,
then well,
what's the problem with taking things
pulling out?
They lose control depending on how much
of this,
how much of the stock are they going to
sell?
You're going to sell 10%.
They're certainly not gonna sell 50.1%
because then they lose total control.
But then there also have to adhere to
the SEC Securities Exchange Commission.
There's rules,
uh,
and they got to have to have audited
statements every,
uh,
every 90 days.
And if there's a,
if,
if they gave you too much money for
expenses and it's down there as a
footnote,
they're going to come.
They come and investigate.
Why did you get Rogan that?
What'd you do that most people don't
want to go public because of that?
I went public because I could see that I
was going to make a thousand times my
money.
I mean,
not even 100,000 times my money.
So it was a no brainer.
We made 100,000 times your money by
going public.
Well,
it,
what's he actually better than that?
The uh,
I Jamie,
we to take this podcast Papa.
Okay.
I grew at 67000% a year.
What the fuck does that even mean?
[inaudible] 67.
My total growth on my original
investment was 55000000%.
Jesus Christ.
That's a lot of money.
And that,
there hasn't been facebook nor anybody
else.
Anybody,
even close by it.
Unfortunately for me,
because it was 25 years ago,
I was at a low bass.
My Bass was only half a million or five.
Yeah.
Excuse me,
500 million.
And,
but now,
I mean,
does that mean by your base?
In other words,
what,
I grew the company from 800 bucks to 500
million.
Okay.
So,
but my base,
my initial base was eight.
Uh,
call it 1000 bucks.
Okay.
In my exit base was 500 million,
$500 million.
And,
uh,
of course I had a lot of shareholders.
It wasn't just me.
Uh,
but now,
uh,
the,
um,
the company
grew.
If you take 800 bucks and you figure out
the,
you do a spreadsheet on a,
the growth per year at 67000%,
and if do the total growth,
it's 55000000%.
55000000%.
Now,
if you were urine MMA fan exam,
give advice to the people that own the
UFC,
what would you tell them?
Alpha brain.
What would you,
what would you give them?
I hire somebody like Goldman Sachs.
Uh,
I hired more than one.
I take Goldman Sachs and jp Morgan or
somebody like that or credit suisse to,
to look at how to make their investment
liquid liquid.
Cause now it's frozen like a stiff dick.
I mean it's not going into place.
So what does that mean?
Like how do you make it liquid?
Liquid.
Okay.
If,
let's just say we're going to take this
podcast public.
Okay.
So let's do it.
Let's go crazy.
Okay,
let's get crazy now.
Let's just say that the,
um,
right now,
uh,
you make a,
let's throw out numbers,
$1 million a year off your podcast.
Uh,
and um,
you have no other shareholders.
Okay?
Just,
okay,
now you want to take it public and you
want to take it public on one of the
secondary tertiary exchanges because,
uh,
this isn't,
wouldn't be big enough to take on the
New York Stock Exchange.
And,
um,
do you want to sell shares in your baby?
A $4,000 a share.
Okay.
How many shares does one half?
Well,
you,
it has been used one if you want to.
So he can make 100 million shares with
$1,000 a share.
Yeah Buddy.
You,
you couldn't,
you couldn't equate that much value,
but you could do a thousand chairs at a
thousand,
$1,000 a share.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
And so you sell 20% off to the public.
So 20% of those shares are,
and I mean you've got millions of people
that follow you.
I mean,
that would be a slam dunk.
it'd be a no brainer.
It'd be a no brainer.
Who's done a bunch of people be telling
me to who I know as long as long as you
got to keep control,
fuck you.
You know,
they would try to get that power though.
They got where they would,
but as long as you held or your group,
your consortium or you and your,
uh,
your buddies held more than 50%,
they could never take control.
But it seems like that's,
that's where hostile takeovers,
correct.
Right.
Correct.
People gather.
I started there.
Yeah.
I'm getting excited myself.
Just thinking about it.
Yes,
I'll take over.
Is that okay?
Well,
we'll meet in the cage.
You can put your best guy up.
I'll put my best gun,
then we'll settle it that way.
Just like they do in the old days,
you know,
instead of the two armies going to war
the best night from this guy and the
best night from this guy.
Who would you pick the defense to defend
your honor.
My arm and the cage.
I mean if you get the other side,
had a guy,
who would you pick?
It's a good question.
Are we doing wait clauses?
No.
And anything goes.
This is a heavyweight named Francis and
Ghana.
I think I might put my money on that
guy.
Yeah.
Terrifying young heavyweight.
Okay.
Who would they be?
Dead.
Who cares what I'm putting out?
Okay.
I used to be a fan of,
uh,
lesnar.
I liked scary,
scary.
If Brock got into
mma when he was young,
if somebody grabbed him like right out
of college and uh,
and really trained him properly,
better yet,
right out of high school and train him
properly.
Just unbelievable freak athlete.
A freak athlete.
I remember in the heavy,
yeah.
Wait,
a match.
I forget who was fought where,
um,
he,
he had beaten up lesnar pretty bad,
but less,
there's still win the fight that guy
with the big hands and other shame
Carwyn yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Shane and beat the shit out of in the
first round.
But he gassed out and then brock
survived and strangled him in a second
at Brock's a tough guy and you know,
he just was a guy who got into mma very
late in life and wasn't a natural
striker and really didn't have the,
the natural striking capability.
Not when I say natural,
I mean like fluid.
Really.
Um,
effortless striking that you get when
you've been doing it for years and years
and years.
That's,
that's one of the hardest things to
learn as guys get older when they're
like in their thirties.
And then learning how to strike,
learning how to strike against someone
who's really seasoned and good.
There's just going to be these openings
and it just takes a few shots.
One,
two,
three,
get in and all of a sudden you're
diminished in the leg kick and then the
fucking shot to the body and you're
hurt.
And then boom,
you saw what happened when he fought
Cain Velasquez.
Cain just overwhelmed them.
It just so much better with striking and
really grit,
great at wrestling as well.
So cain was able to get back up on its
feet when brock took them down and then
just brought,
could not handle the onslaught that
came,
was putting on him on the feet.
Just wasn't prepared for it correctly.
You need years and years and years of
striking training and you need to spar
lightly and you need to,
you know,
you need to develop fluidity and you in
your movements,
you need to have efficient striking
mood.
Now what's it called?
The,
uh,
the,
the pretend wrestling league.
Uh,
pro wrestling.
Wwe.
Yeah.
Okay.
You know,
uh,
what's the guy's name?
The founder,
Vince Mcmahon.
I'm a man and his wife is now in the,
in the cabinet,
uh,
for trump.
And she got approved.
Hilarious.
Yes.
Holly is hilarious.
But she or not she,
they got rich when they went public.
Yeah.
See they went public.
They went public with the wwe.
Correct.
And I was offered for $50,000 a point
when they first got started,
a bunch of buddies of mine in
Connecticut,
we're riding in a limo and they show me
a demo tape and he says,
we can get into this weekend by up to
10% for $50,000 a point.
They need money.
I said,
well shit.
Who's going to watch that shit?
Nah,
I feel that same way my friend Tony was
at,
um,
I don't know what they call it.
Monday night raw.
Is that what it was at the staple center
and he was making videos while he was in
the audience.
And I was like,
you gotta be fucking shitting me.
There's 20,000 people in this place.
It's crazy.
The numbers are insane.
People love that stuff.
They love it.
I can't buy these.
I don't understand it.
Yeah.
But I mean that,
that,
that's,
he got liquid by going public.
How many people do you think that pay
$3,000 a month to that guy wound up
going to pro pro wrestling and the same
people?
Probably the $3,000 yeah,
probably the same
people.
That's probably like 100% of them are
pro wrestling fans.
Yeah.
Now does everybody know po pro wrestling
is not for real?
No.
There's some people who have had
injuries out there that says there's a
few,
few people that fell off the back of a
motorcycle and the little girl booby
wound,
well it's all on Prague was number one.
This is soon when they come down they
the the the runway amp and the fire and
this and that.
And then when they get,
they have to be good,
good athletes,
boom.
When they bounce their heads and some of
those things you hit him with chairs
does.
Definitely good athletes.
Yeah.
Does the guys are outstanding athletes
and it's a fucking really hard way to
make a living.
I mean w whatever it say,
whatever the fuck you want about it
being choreographed.
They're still picking each other up and
slamming each other on the ground.
And hitting each other and it's got to
hurt after a few weeks,
few months,
few years,
not only down.
Those guys are on the road,
you know,
200 plus days a year doing that.
So it is a absolutely brutal business.
It's a hard way to make a living and
they are tough,
tough guys.
So they might not be really competing
like an MMA fighter is,
but there's no doubt about it.
They have my respect.
Those guys are tough.
That's a tough way to make a living.
They are earning their money and I think
they're doing it in a way where most
people don't even see them earn their
money.
They mean they're out in these,
these arenas.
You know,
they're,
they're playing this state and that
state and they're going on the road and
they're slamming each other and throwing
each other into the turnbuckle and
elbowing each other in the face.
It's fucking hard,
man.
That is a hard way to make a living.
And a giant percentage of those guys
wind up having problems with pain pills,
severe pain and their body always
constantly,
you know,
back injuries,
knee injuries,
neck injuries,
elbow injuries,
me,
it's just,
it's a fucking brutal way to get paid.
Now are the a mea guys getting paid big
money now?
The best of the best are the guys like
conor Mcgregor and conor mcgregor.
A lot of the people that fight conor
Mcgregor,
they're making millions.
Ronda Rousey,
she's making millions.
It's just,
uh,
it's taken a while for the people that
are not known very well to be able to
make that kind of money.
You know,
they're not,
they're not really,
you know,
it's,
it's hard for the average journeyman
fighter to not just pay their bills,
but to put money away as well.
You know,
it's just,
but it's like that in boxing too.
This is what people don't understand.
Boxing like you,
people say,
well,
floyd mayweather made $40 million for
that fight.
Maybe he did,
but floyd mayweather's one,
there's one floyd mayweather.
Gennady Golovkin can't sell 200,000
paper view bys.
And he's the one of the best fighters in
the world today.
You know,
Vassily Limit Chanko same thing.
One of the best fighters in the world
today.
He's not making the kind of money to
conor Mcgregor's making.
So what boxing is,
is like you see these very big marquee
names,
you know,
these big famous guys who are making
good money and um,
they make more money than the best UFC
guys.
Like Manny Pacquiao has made more money
than the best UFC guys.
But conor mcgregor is nipping at their
heels right now.
Yeah,
man.
He used to have a
house right around the corner from me.
I lived eight years in Manila,
one year in China.
Thriller in Manila.
Yeah.
Wow.
What does that like,
if you've got money,
it's terrific.
Is it dangerous?
Yeah.
My,
my wife had six bodyguards,
Jesus Christ,
six,
six and one of them used to be the
bodyguard to the president and the a all
I want you there.
Why live in there?
I had a thriving business.
I still have the thrive in business and
we don't live there anymore.
Play Pool.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I know you did.
If you live in Manila,
you gotta play some pool and a while.
We live in a year in China,
eight years.
There are three years in India and um,
the,
uh,
but when I was interviewing bodyguards,
I just want to know,
have you ever gotten any trigger time?
I don't want you to just looking pretty,
I mean did you ever pulled the fucking
trigger?
So all the are all of my wife's body
guards had pulled triggers before,
you know,
because you could get,
get these guys I've read the same with
CIA or the secret shoppers.
I mean have you done anything,
you know,
well that's it.
That is an important thing and it's a,
some would consider maybe like there's
some people that are more sensitive that
will say,
well that's distasteful thing to even
bring up.
Like why is their honor and shooting
people while I was there on a tray or
12.
But I think what you were trying to
figure out when you went into this big
game hunting with handguns thing,
whether or not you,
you would pussy out when the moment was
there is because you knew that it's a
significant challenge when your life is
legitimately on the line.
People Act different when they think
they're going to die.
I mean,
they just do.
They just do that just to find out who
you really are versus who you're
pretending that you are holy.
You know?
And I know a lot of brave guys that have
piss their pants course themselves,
but they,
they did with it was necessary.
But that,
that moment of truth.
Well that's the old saying that a great
man and a weak man have the same fear.
Just one response to it a different way.
Yeah.
I raised my kid does not what happens to
you in life,
it's how you react to what happens to
you in life.
And the um,
and the,
the millennial kids are buzzies weenies
they wouldn't even call them vagina
brains.
Oh yeah.
What was that?
They wanted to get laid.
They don't know how though.
But isn't a vagina good thing or not?
If you've got one is the brain,
do you realize jellyfish lasted 350
million years without a brain?
Yeah,
but they don't have google.
You can't find them on snapchat.
Who gives a fuck about jellyfish?
Sting you.
They're assholes.
Yeah.
What are they?
You can't even eat him.
No,
you can't.
You can't even eat jellyfish.
No,
I'm useless.
The pardon?
What do they do?
What's good is do they just throw it
around in a string of the fish to kill
them assholes.
Yeah.
And they fuck with you and you're at the
beach.
Yeah.
And there's some weird fucking super
ancient life form correctly in years
past to people.
Hopefully we move past,
hopefully,
you know,
but they know global warming to joke to
the jellyfish to,
yeah.
Oh,
well this is a thing.
I've had this conversation with people
before because you know,
if you have anybody on a podcast that
is,
uh,
the saying anything controversial,
like you're saying about global warming,
people go,
oh my God,
can't believe you had a climate change
denier on your show,
but you're not a climate change denier,
which you're saying is that it's an
exaggerated effect that human beings
have had.
And regardless of whether or not we had
that effect at all,
if you look at like the end of the Ice
Age,
you look at all these different
monumental changes in the temperature of
the United States versus the temperature
of the world,
the global globally.
It's constantly changing.
Yeah.
55,000 years ago at the South Pole,
South Pole,
it was two degrees Celsius warmer.
And my wife and I've also been to the
magnetic North Pole.
We were married there as well.
We're bipolar in the south.
And why did you get married in weird
spots?
Um,
for fun.
Yeah,
for fun,
crazy life.
And I renewed our vows six times.
Jesus Christ.
He must really love that lady.
Well,
I do.
And,
uh,
but the North Pole is,
um,
uh,
they,
they all look pretty much the same,
but most people don't realize the South
Pole on a mountain.
So you're at altitude,
you're at between 10 and 14,000 feet.
Uh,
so,
uh,
well countries,
the South Pole in Antarctica,
Antarctica is the South Pole is the
mountain.
And what's the North Pole?
North Pole.
Just movie.
Nice.
Just moving on.
So there's no actual mass on the eyes
and only three to six weeks a year.
Can you actually have a facility to be
able to land the chopper,
uh,
and have a ceremony at the North Pole?
Is that a normal thing where people get
a ceremony on the oh no.
Sally and I are at right now the
Guinness Book of Records is going
through the witnesses or the only two
people that need to be married on both
poles.
You didn't realize the Guinness Book of
record,
their scam,
they charge you money.
How much?
Well,
to get on the preferred list,
a thousand pounds,
dollars.
It's like 1400 bucks.
1300 bucks.
Most people don't pay it and most people
don't get in.
So you have to pay money to get on their
stupid book.
Correct.
So even if you did something like,
say if you jump rope for three days
straight and you made the Guinness Book
of World Records,
you'd have to pay to get in that six,
seven years to get on what?
Yeah.
Why?
Because that's their model.
Their money.
What a bunch of fucking,
this is probably the first time that
anybody's ever told anybody on a public,
uh,
medium.
We've had like four first on this
podcast.
I'm pretty proud of that.
You and me.
Yeah,
we've had right Devon,
he said,
you said quite a few firsts,
Alan saying another one.
Okay.
My Pa,
my pet project right now is,
I'm trying to put together a vet veteran
program and a that I'm funding.
I put up all the money.
I don't want anybody's money.
But so,
so far,
even though I had one of the world's
largest talent agencies and I had 'em 10
of the top 15 production companies say
that vets don't make good tv.
Now they won't say that in public.
What do they mean by Vet Stone?
Veteran TV veterans don't make good tv
unless they're rattling around in the
mud.
Well,
that's what I've been told by some names
that you probably know even.
And,
uh,
the,
um,
I've been told by four star generals
names that positively everybody on this
podcast with,
no,
I've been told by congressmen,
senators,
I've been told by TV personalities.
Dot.
Moving heads on,
you know,
that all come out for vets except when
they're asked to do something and we
don't,
I don't want their money.
So what kind of stuff are you talking
about?
Like do something,
okay.
No,
I mean,
will you be in an advisory board saying
that,
uh,
putting bets in business after they
tried,
they tried to transition from the
military to a civilian life and try to
reduce the 22 veterans,
commit suicide a day,
you know,
uh,
and um,
then when on CBS to say,
yeah,
yeah.
But when you ask them to do something,
they're,
they're not as,
um,
uh,
generous with her time.
And,
uh,
I can understand,
if I was asking them for money,
but what I found out,
Joe,
all these guys save a few stomach need
to make a living
and they're not going to get paid for
this.
So they have less time,
pro bono time and charity time.
Then they let people on when they're in
a,
on CNBC,
etc. Right.
I see what you're saying.
Okay.
So I've been asked to do a documentary
expos.
A
I've been asked that I haven't said I
was going to do it cause I don't really
need that kind of publicity.
But um,
about this show that I've been trying to
do,
I don't know.
What is the show?
What's it called?
Boots to suits.
Okay.
So taking them from the military and
then teaching them how to has five pilot
programs at the castle where I do my
seminars and with Vats,
uh,
sometimes we make gum a castle.
Okay.
You're saying when you say that the
castle is that I'm not going to come
back.
Yeah,
I live in a 14th century.
Storybook cancelled.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Where is it?
Oh,
stop me.
You live in Scotland?
Yeah.
Yeah,
near Saint Andrews.
Jeez.
Why do you live in Scotland?
You all over the place,
man,
because I want them to be,
I wanted to be near the home of golf
when I were tried.
I tried to retire in my thirties when I
made uh,
and just play golf.
Yeah.
But I only lasted a couple of months.
Retirement.
Didn't know.
No,
I mean you don't seem like a guy that
can be done now.
It didn't suit me.
It,
um,
it doesn't suit me now.
I haven't had to work for 37 years now.
How did you get involved in all this
online stuff?
Cause that's how I found out about you
and I found out about you through Sam's
a girl.
I mean,
I,
I got involved online because I owned
businesses that mark it online.
But you,
you're a great online advice guy.
Yeah.
Oh No,
no.
I mean a five of the top online.
Many producers on the planet.
I trained like who are the top five
guys?
Well,
I'm Matt Lloyd.
Um,
Shakir Hussein.
I feel like this is like he's telling me
about all stars in a sport.
I don't fall.
Ah,
pat copious,
uh,
Shakir pattern or was dude's no,
no.
Yeah.
These guys make three to 7 million a
month.
Jesus,
that's a lot of money.
I hope you're paying taxes.
Boys pay that tax.
You,
I know one of them for sure believes in
no taxation without representation.
Oh,
one of those guys,
Huh?
Yeah.
I,
in fact,
almost all of them are that willing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
So when I trained them,
but I didn't train her,
you know,
I know about impressions and trap.
I don't understand all that.
But when Google changed their algorithms
10,
12 years ago,
they used to want a hundred guys that
produced 100 million online.
Now they want 10 million guys that
produce 10,000 online.
Ah,
yeah.
And so that's how they built their
platform.
And uh,
and Google is,
I is a great tool,
but a better tool in my judgment for
what I do is linkedin.
Yeah.
Linkedin is some shit that people from
high school we send me.
I want to pitch them on joining linkedin
page.
Huh?
Are you on Linkedin?
No.
No,
but I get like invitations.
Oh yeah.
Join linkedin more than anything I ever
get an online.
Okay.
And I don't join.
Well,
I mean,
linkedin is a,
is is a professional thing.
I know.
That's why it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
They sending that crap to me.
Um,
but your professional,
even though you pretend not to be,
oh,
I pretend.
Yes.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Does that your perception tending not to
people?
It's true.
That's your shtick.
My shtick is that I pretended not your
shtick is you pretend to be outside the
box.
When I believe that you're more inside
the box,
then these,
these melon heads listening know or
realize we're like,
what do you mean by in the box?
I mean,
you're a,
you have some,
I know you're a libertarian.
If my research is correct,
pretty much.
Okay.
And I realized,
uh,
but you,
I mean,
you believe in some real Downer of
values,
uh,
that,
um,
are actually in the box that made
America great.
Would you disagree?
Uh,
yeah,
probably define those.
Like,
what do you mean?
Uh,
you've talked about,
we've talked briefly about,
um,
commitment,
focus,
hard work discipline.
Yeah.
For sure.
I made this country great.
Well that's what makes people great.
Well,
okay,
well people make a country.
Comfort is not what makes people great.
No.
And uh,
the,
uh,
getting out of your comfort zone is the
reason that millennials have such a hard
time now.
Yeah.
They're all sitting on the couch playing
video games and Fox still limited food
delivered 34 years old.
That's true.
I can't believe that.
Yeah.
When I was 18,
I couldn't get out of the house quick
enough.
But don't you think that that's sort of
like what we always expect from the fall
of civilizations?
I mean,
that's what we always were taught about
Rome,
right.
That Rome got to be incredibly
gluttonous and then it all collapsed the
way it's on bullshit.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's kind of like,
you don't think that's going to happen
to the u s or it's America right now?
Absolutely.
I couldn't more.
But do you think it'd be,
can be changed?
Can it be turned around?
Can Be changed.
If we want to do it bad enough,
we're willing to pay the price to
action.
It's going to be painful.
Well,
I think people just need to understand
that there's consequences.
There's consequences that you pay to
constantly seeking comfort and avoiding
discomfort and avoiding hard work.
And those consequences are you never
going to feel self realized.
He never going to feel like you
accomplished anything.
He never going to have this feeling of
understanding that difficulty and
struggle and,
and the ability to push through that is
a muscle.
And you develop that muscle by doing it.
And once you do,
you develop a lot of self satisfaction
and you develop peace of mind and you,
you understand that you can overcome
obstacles if you don't have to overcome
obstacles.
You never know whether or not you can,
like what you were talking about with
trigger time,
unless you were faced with actual
adversity.
You don't understand how you're going to
feel and how you're gonna react when you
overcome that adversity.
The,
um,
uh,
one of the things I believe that I'm the
best on the planet in doing is I get you
to do,
which you don't want to do to be what
you want to be.
What do you,
what do I need to do?
Tell me.
Well,
I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
that's the first time I ever met you.
You know,
you're,
you're an enigma inside a,
what's that saying?
Wrapped and secrets or track,
something like that.
And,
and,
uh,
the,
um,
but so,
I mean,
hopefully this isn't the last time I
ever talked to you,
but I mean your,
um,
your,
you're an idol to,
you know,
as several million people,
those people need help.
I'm the wrong guy.
Yeah.
Well keep moving.
These are not the droids you're looking
for.
And,
uh,
but,
um,
what,
what I do and before they put dirt on me
in 50 more years is I want to minimize
people's regrets.
Okay.
And because we all have regrets.
Uh,
and I told you what my three regrets or
a earlier in your program here,
but I mean the minimize regrets and uh,
the millennials,
uh,
we'll have a different sort of regrets.
Uh,
the,
uh,
right now,
um,
for the past seven or eight years we've
had free money.
Interest rates had been free.
It's literally free a hundred years from
now.
They're going to say,
what the fuck were you doing when they
were giving away free money?
I mean,
literally the people that are listening
to this 20 years from now,
their children and grandchildren are
going to say,
grandma,
Grandpa,
what the fuck were you doing other than
having your thumb up your ass during the
period of free money?
No.
When you say interest rates are free,
you talking about business loans,
correct?
I mean,
you can,
it's never going to get,
well,
it can only go up from here.
And,
and uh,
yellen,
the head of the Fed Federal Reserve has
already up to him once and they,
she says,
I guess she's going to have a couple
more times,
but historically interest,
which tried to be eight,
10,
12,
not two,
three.
If you can't make a business proposition
work at two or 3% interest.
So you pay one or two points over that
which is the vigorous or the interest
that they get you out to swallow.
And I'm only mean this metaphorically
kids.
You ought to swallow a fucking revolver.
Wow.
Let's try again because now if you can't
make money now,
you ought to jump in front of a bus.
Now when you go and do these seminars,
like finally give him at the council.
I don't give seminars around the world
anymore.
I stopped that in 2000 and uh,
to when the,
the century change.
But you just did this speech or speech,
I'm just to,
I guess they'd call it a solid that the
right word.
Solid.
You're doing a solid,
yeah.
Is that,
does that favor?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm doing a favor for the guy,
but so the seminars are only at the
castle,
we will have to come to your castle.
Correct.
And when they do,
like what do you,
what do you work on them?
What do you like to fill out?
About 120 pages of copious paperwork on
them.
Psychological profiles and much of this
stuff.
And do you have someone go over that or
do you go with that?
Personally,
I'd have many people do you do this with
20 to 24 per seminar.
Wow.
And how long,
how many days is the seminar?
Uh,
eight.
Eight days.
So the first thing I have to dress in a
suit.
You have to dress in a suit and the suit
and you have to start at eight in the
morning and it goes til midnight.
Jesus Christ.
So you basically go on to sleep,
getting up,
going to work again?
Correct.
Trade days?
Wow.
And uh,
they can't use,
I have two gymnasiums at the castle,
but they can't use the gymnasium unless
they earn it.
You have to earn it.
You have to show me something that you
got to have more than a,
a,
a jelly fish brain.
Hang.
The last two seminars didn't have any
gym time.
No gym time.
Nope.
Hmm.
No gym time.
So they just didn't earn it.
Yeah.
They didn't earn it.
He had only about half of them cried the
last seminar.
Only half and one half.
How come the other maybe had a pair?
I don't know.
When they cry.
What are they crying from?
Uh,
the buttons.
The emotional buttons.
We have two bank accounts in life.
You as well.
Okay.
Well we have an emotional bank account
in the financial bank account.
Okay.
Most people are not successful.
Not because they run out of their
financial bank account.
They're not successful because they went
out of the emotional bank account.
Ah.
Interestingly,
how so?
Okay.
I'll,
I'll explain a little,
uh,
addition to that.
People come to me for either they're
inspired or desperate.
Even the few people that think they're
inspired aren't,
they're desperate.
I'm the last,
I'm the last town saloon.
He have tried Tony,
uh,
grant cardone.
Jay Abraham.
You've tried every mother fucker that
walks,
that tells you it's easy to be
successful.
I tell you just the opposite.
It's a motherfucker to be successful.
And uh,
so when you come to me and I look
through your psychological profile and I
measure you a day by day,
uh,
sitting there,
for 14,
16 hours a day,
um,
then you have one hour private time with
me and I go through this,
uh,
you know why you're really here.
I asked you what's the most defining
moment in your life up to today.
I mean,
coming here,
what's the most defining moment for your
siblings?
What's the most defining moment of,
um,
uh,
your parents?
Uh,
why do you think it's defining,
Oh,
my dad got out of jail for the last
time,
you know.
Okay.
We've had convicted murderers at
seminar.
Yeah.
Convicted murderers.
I did their time,
you know,
as long as you're not an obvious,
and I'll get in trouble for this.
Obvious,
I'm
a cross dresser.
Whew.
You can come to the sort of feel like a
non obvious crossdresser well,
I mean you wear your regular clothes you
should be wearing,
in other words,
if you are a man,
dress like a woman,
right?
You got to dress like a man.
But what if you're a man who really
looks like a woman and he's dressed like
a woman?
No.
It as I don't see him naked.
Okay.
As long as him naked.
Yeah,
I understand.
You just don't want any disruptions.
Correct.
You don't even want any aberrations,
anything that's weird that gets in the
way of what you're trying to be weird
anyway.
I mean,
when you see grown men cry and bigger
than me sobbing uncontrollably,
I mean,
well,
what causes them to this emotional bank
county you were talking about?
You have a financial bank account to
bank account.
That'll give you an example.
Okay.
Um,
a guy who,
uh,
was raised in a whorehouse,
his mom is a whore.
He knew that his mom was a horse and
she's a six,
seven,
eight.
He still lives in the whorehouse.
How old is he?
26.
Jesus Christ.
How old his mom?
50 I think.
50?
No,
she like oil or just like,
I've never met him going down per
gallon.
Uh,
I don't know,
but she's the MME now.
Oh,
she's not servicing to me.
That's crazy.
And he lives there.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
What kind of bags do you think that kid
has fucked?
Yeah.
Yup.
Tarred.
And a,
what was the worst thing you ever saw
your mother do?
You know,
tears are streaming down his cheeks and
I go,
he goes,
um,
there's too many to count.
Mr Penny,
do you think about it every night?
He says,
yes.
How did you know Mr [inaudible]?
How do you not know?
Exactly.
Yeah.
And He's successful.
The little shit hosing.
Yeah.
What'd he do?
A,
he's a,
an engineer.
He's doing these women,
end up small engineering firms.
Wow.
That's a hard way to grow up,
man.
Yup.
When,
I mean,
if loved got the job done,
okay,
we'd have a perfect world now.
We'd have no wars.
If love debit that got the job done
right.
You love doesn't get the fucking job
done.
What does get the job done?
Pulling the trigger,
taken action,
following your dream.
So when you have these guys crying,
you're just sort of explore exposing to
them what emotional baggage they're
carrying around with them that's
hindering their professional life.
Correct.
Well that amongst a bunch of this stuff.
Yeah,
but that's kind of a,
it couldn't be a good summary.
So by this eight day pressure cooker
that you put these guys through it,
when you're making them work all day for
eight days in a row,
you,
you essentially like establish like this
is what it's like to try to be
successful.
You have to funnel to be,
to be a high,
my market
is to turn people into the top.
This just say the 7 billion people on
the planet.
Right.
My market is 700,000 you want to be one
of those 700,000 high performance
individuals.
You come and see me.
I want to go right now.
Okay.
I'm not even,
no,
no glad a lot.
Last week,
the week before last,
we may just three announcements of three
of our guys.
One Guy who is a monkey,
looks like a,
you know,
you were talking about chimpanzees.
He looks like a chimpanzee.
He did a billion dollar deal with
Goldman Sachs.
Well,
you couldn't smell Goldman Sachs or a
billion and he did a billion dollar deal
and he,
he actually looks like a chimpanzee
social.
Oops.
Okay.
Another guy,
uh,
he had $181 million deal and Australian,
he weighs 200 kilos.
That's a lot.
That's a big fucker.
Big fucker.
During the 400 pounds and a 440 pounds
during the graduate,
adore during the graduation on 'em we
go,
we went to Edinburgh for new years eve.
Uh,
he got stuck and he got stuck in the,
uh,
in the toilet.
In the bus.
Okay.
He got stuck.
He couldn't get out.
Yeah.
How'd you get them out?
I wasn't there.
Well,
my wife said,
why aren't we going on the bus with
them?
Shit's going to happen and I don't want
to be there.
Literally.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
And another guy,
and I get this,
he had a closing.
He came to me when he was 17 years old.
He had a closing in Washington dc a few
days ago and sally and I were there.
When you close it financial,
do you have to have two sources of id
now because of money laundering,
et Cetera.
He had a passport.
A second source of ID was a driver's
permit because he's not old enough to
have a driver's license.
He had a driver's permit and a passport.
He did a $3 million deal.
Jesus,
he's a teenager.
The reason why teenagers do better is
because they have less baggage.
Uh,
that makes sense.
They haven't had as much life wearing
them down,
not as much scar tissue,
scar tissue,
scar tissue.
That's real shit.
Right.
If you take a kid 18 it's got physical
attributes,
you can train him into being in a guy,
probably easier than you take a 38 year
old.
100%.
Yeah.
So yeah.
It's almost impossible.
Yeah.
Well,
unless they're a super freak athletes,
it's been involved in something versus
freak athletes.
The Black Guy Jones,
John Jones.
Yeah.
Cause he's still around.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
He looked,
he,
somebody broke,
known him was,
he's not the guy that got a broken leg.
No,
that's Anderson Silva.
Then Jones got finally get beat.
Jones has never lost.
The only time he lost was he was
disqualified in a fight against Matt
Hamill where he was dropping.
It's a really stupid rule,
but you're not allowed when you're a on
top of a guy to drop an elbow from the
12 to six position.
Yeah.
Okay,
so he got to squat,
but he beat the fuck out of that guy.
Still the roundup loss.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's,
he's on the suspension right now for
testing positive for a banned substance
and desilva came back.
Anderson Silva came back,
broken leg.
I remember seeing
that.
Jesus Christ,
that was terrible.
That's one of two broken legs I've ever
seen like that live.
I've seen him on videos before,
but being there live here at snap,
I did not hear it snap,
but I saw a give out and I saw him fall
down.
I knew it,
what it was the first time I'd ever seen
it was a guy named Corey Hill.
He threw this kick and the same thing is
like,
it's kicked,
got checked and his legs just snapped
out from under him.
And that time that the referee didn't
see it,
the referee didn't know.
The guy had a broken leg and we were
screaming at the referee to stop the
fight.
It was a,
I was at Mike Tyson's,
uh,
when you win the championship in
bringing really wow.
And that was in the third row and uh,
Deniro and a bunch of Italian guys were
behind me Devito and he was,
well he,
the guy that lost that,
he looked like he was going to lose.
He looked afraid at Tyson and Tyson was
hitting him with such velocity.
The perspiration on the guys head was
flying over the first two rows on to me
in the third bowl.
I mean he was hitting like,
let's sledgehammer.
Yeah,
when he was in his prime,
he was something special.
It really was.
It was a really interesting article.
I just read about him in sports
illustrated.
It's fascinating seeing him now at 50
years old,
you know,
family man doing his vegas show and I
bet she can still hit oh fuck yeah.
There was a video of him hitting the
bag.
It's still terrifying.
I mean,
he's still Mike Tyson.
Yeah.
And one of the greatest boxers of all
time.
The money,
the most fearsome heavyweight that ever
lived in his prime.
There was nobody liked him.
Yeah,
I was on a,
on a Concorde with Muhammad Ali.
Uh,
and um,
the,
uh,
and he,
had his Angelo Dundee is that the guy he
had his entourage with him and uh,
the,
uh,
he was very nice man.
Very nice.
Uh,
only met him that one time.
And uh,
that's not true.
I was in the cotton club in 1978.
Cotton club,
black nightclub used to be.
And um,
the,
uh,
there was a black comedian and I was
trying to,
uh,
read,
at Fox,
right Fox and I'm the only white guy in
the audience.
And he said something about white
people.
So I had been tuned up pretty good.
And then back in [inaudible] 78,
I thought it was pretty tough.
I stood up and I said something back to
them.
Now this went over like a Turd in a
punch bowl.
I mean,
all these people that are around me,
all the color of Fox.
And so fox is,
Eh,
you don't want you to come up here.
And so I go,
and then Muhammad Ali was sitting about
six tables over and he protected me.
He said,
we've got to let this white boy alone.
I mean,
we don't want a problem here.
So then I say,
well,
yeah,
you don't have to protect me.
And I've just was a idiot facility.
Young man.
Yeah,
yeah.
And uh,
I tried to pay the bill and Muhammad Ali
says,
no,
your money's no good here.
The money's nothing.
Oh,
no.
Yeah.
They didn't,
not forcibly believe,
but,
but essentially they know it's over.
Yeah.
Then I told her,
get out of here with your life.
You correct.
Correct.
But anyway,
so,
but um,
yeah,
I had a big mouth.
Listen.
Damn.
Penny,
you've lived a very interesting life.
Thank you.
Really have.
And so if people want to learn more
about your stuff and a,
if anybody ever wants to go to the
castle and go through this a crazy eight
day seminar,
how do they get in touch with you,
Dan pena.com all right,
and it's Dan s Pena is your twitter
handle and I put it up on my twitter or
Google $50 billion man.
All right,
buddy,
because that created $50 billion for
guys just like you.
Just like me.
Yeah.
All right.
Well appreciate you doing that.
Well,
appreciate you coming on here too.
It was a pleasure,
man.
My pleasure.
Thank you very much.
All right.
That's it.
Folks will be back on a Sunday.
We're not going to be here Saturday,
but we're going to do a recap of the
fights.
We're going to watch them on Sunday,
so I'll see you then.
Bye.
Cell.